jonathan blow is a universally acclaimed
video game designer and programmer who's
best known as the creator of the video
games braid and the witness jonathan is
distinguished as a game designer in that
he doesn't think video games should be
considered escapism or shouldn't be
designed to be escapes but rather they
should be experiences to advise you in
your everyday life in the same way that
superlative literature does we touch on
what creativity means free will physics
at least with regard to wolfram's model
and what consciousness has to do with
video games and art in general click on
the timestamp in the description if
you'd like to skip this intro for those
new to this channel my name is kurt
jaimungal i'm a filmmaker with a
background in mathematical physics
dedicated to the exploitation of what
are called theories of everything from a
theoretical physics perspective but as
well as delineating the possible
connection consciousness has to the
fundamental laws of nature provided
these laws exist at all and are even
knowable to us if you enjoy witnessing
and engaging in conversation on the
topics of psychology physics
consciousness and so on then check the
description for an invitation to the
discord and the theories of everything
subreddit there's also a link to the
patreon that is patreon.com
c-u-r-t j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l
kercher mongol if you'd like to support
this podcast as the patrons and the
sponsors are the only reason i'm able to
do this full-time it would be near
impossible at least for me to have
conversations on loop quantum gravity
non-dualism consciousness even geometric
unity with any sort of fidelity if not
for your support thank you and that link
again is patreon.com
kurtjmungle with regard to sponsors
there are two algo is an end-to-end
supply chain optimization software
company with software that helps
business users optimize sales and
operations planning to avoid stockouts
reduce returns and inventory write-downs
while reducing inventory investment it's
a supply chain ai that drives smart roi
headed by a bright individual by the
name of amjad hussein who's been a huge
supporter of this podcast since near its
inception the second sponsor is
brilliant brilliant illuminates the soul
of mathematics science and engineering
through bite-sized interactive learning
experiences that explore the laws that
shape our world it elevates math and
science from something to be feared to a
delightful experience of guided
discovery you can even learn group
theory which is what's being referenced
when people say that the standard model
is based upon u1 cross su-2 cross s23
those are technically called lead groups
visit brilliant.org
tow t-o-e for free and get 20 off the
annual subscription i recommend that you
don't stop before four lessons and i
think you'll be greatly surprised at the
ease at which you can now comprehend
subjects that you previously had
difficulty grocking thank you and enjoy
this conversation with the world
renowned jonathan blow before conducting
the podcast i was asking jonathan about
why he accepted this interview given
that he's requested to be on many
channels and says no to the majority of
them
um
i think these days it's down to like
what do i feel like is the motivation of
the person
doing the interview right like if it's
somebody who
you know just wants clicks or i mean
it's worse actually to to tangent a
little bit
um i've had really bad experiences like
at live physical conferences because
those like i prepare a different speech
to do every time i put
a lot of last minute work into doing
this thing and then i go have the
interaction with the person running the
conference and i realize oh
this person just wants me here to like
get some audience and doesn't really
care about anything that i have you know
and and those um
that
has it's just gotten me to be more to
conserve my energy more i guess and try
to use it in in cases where um
where i feel like somebody just wants to
legitimately have a conversation right
as opposed to like you know whatever and
so there's all sorts of emails that i
get that i don't
um
i don't even reply to
you know
ranging from
do you want to
speak i mean these days it's usually
online conferences right do you want to
speak at our online conference to like
i'm in high school and my teacher wants
us to interview people right and it's
like those are sweet
there i mean maybe but also maybe not
like because maybe it's just oh i just
picked someone i don't know it could be
a rule or that they're not genuinely
interested in you
yeah
um
it's hard to know like it's also just
hard to know um
but
i do also there's one thing going on
which is
like i generally
only want to
do talks when i really have something to
say
which is interesting to see how this is
gonna go because it's not like i have a
particular idea
uh
for what
what i want to get across right it's
totally open conversation but um
like i've just i've seen a lot of people
um
this is a kind of an indus industry lens
on things or something okay but you see
people and
they seem like smart people in a certain
field
but then you watch them for years or
they're the people around you and
they're just talking and talking and it
eventually turns out
they were like playing this talking game
as opposed to
like really being the people invested in
like wanting to know and wanting to work
hard and do the thing and so
um i always i have this secondary reflex
to like check that tendency in myself
like hey
is it really better
if you maybe don't talk so much right
now and just go
um
just go work on something and what do
you mean when you say they're playing
the talking game that they want to be a
guru or a pundit of some sort more than
they care about the message they're
delivering they want to be someone who's
seen as a message delivery yeah i mean i
think that's a very fundamental human
motivation right
or or i mean not fundamental to
everybody let's say common it's a
it's a common thing that people do
um
either to get ahead societally or
to just feel to themselves like they're
succeeding right like we all sort of
especially these days
um in the us there's not a lot of like
social prescription
for
how to
who you're supposed to be right like the
at least the culture that i grew up in
um was just sort of like here you go go
figure it out right go figure out what
you're doing and
um
that means
there's this thing that happens where
people figure out their own angle on
some particular thing and they think
that they're
it maybe looks like two people are doing
the same thing so if i do video game
stuff and i go to a conference and
here's a guy giving a speech about
something and here's another guy giving
a speech about something and
one of them may be doing this
in order to be a pundit right
and
think but but he doesn't realize that's
what he's doing right because he he just
thinks he's being smart about the the
topic and whatever but
his way of figuring out
how to orient in the world just
somehow
has more of this
more of the pundit
in pundit ingredient and less of the
actual fascination with the fundamental
material ingredient and it can be hard
to tell those things apart and sometimes
it takes time but then you see the
trajectory of
what happens over time and it it sort of
it separates these things out right
i don't know
you know i've been following you for
when i say following you i've known
about you and have been a fan of you
for
more than 10 years
many more than 10 years
all right i don't remember exactly what
it was but you influenced me so i'm a
filmmaker i always say i'm a filmmaker
first more than i'm a podcaster or a
or someone who dabbles in math and
physics and so on i'm a filmmaker i'm
more of a formal artist and what i mean
by that is i i play with the form
of art
i'm interested in
games that let's say
they only consist of endings
or
sure yeah braid was a great example
braid i love the ending particularly the
last part of braid where not to spoil it
spoiler alert where
you reverse the direction of time and
you see that you thought that you were
saving this person but you were the
villain from her perspective my films
basically i try to play with the formal
aspect and i realized as i was
performing some introspection that
plenty of that is owed to you
that's always nice to hear you know i
mean it
what i do is hard it takes a lot of work
right
somehow i ended up in this medium
that probably takes more work than any
other medium like per thing produced at
least the way that i do it
um
so
uh it's really nice to hear that these
things have an impact
in one way or another you know
yeah
do you have a video game philosophy
and if so can you just give the overview
of it for the audience
i am
i'm not sure that i think about it
exactly that way i mean i i think that i
could give a good answer to that
question
if we go into it by more specific parts
you know because what what i have is
something that
i've put together over
decades as a result of a few different
things right one is like
how did i get into this
it seems on the one hand it seems really
natural that i ended up where i am but
on the other hand it seems really weird
um
and so
like whatever my motivations were
originally
gave me a certain
angle on things right
um
okay how about this you said in one of
the interviews i believe it's a recent
one a few months ago that one of your
goals in life is to understand the
universe maybe that's your dominant goal
so firstly what does it mean to
understand the universe
yeah you know i'm not actually
this is a difficult question right i
mean
so so
yeah
no i mean what i would say in response
to that question is
um that was very very definitely
um
a strong guiding motivator or maybe the
only motivator when i was young before i
was actually officially in games like
when
in the 80s when i had home computers and
i was just like doing hobbyist stuff
but i even then i knew it was a hard
question and i knew that any answer that
i
could predict would be extremely
unsatisfactory right it wouldn't be a
real answer and so i knew i was setting
myself up for a very very very hard
thing
now like what's interesting is
i sort of got into doing game stuff
almost
as a temporary reprieve from that as
like
oh man you know this thing it's too hard
i'm ins there was a time in life when i
felt like i am i am insufficient to
uh to approach this problem without
being completely destroyed therefore
my job is actually
um
to go away for a little bit and get
stronger
and
later
i'll know something better about how to
approach this right when you say this
you mean the problem of understanding
the universe
and what do you mean that you'll be
destroying yes and also how old were you
when you had that thought so first so
two questions how old were you when you
had a thought what do you mean by you'll
be destroyed by yourself this was uh you
know around sometime when i was in
college so i was probably
i was probably like 20 years old or
something like that
um 19 maybe
um
and i would say that that part of my
personality at this time
was
so
you know i knew looking around hey we
have a world full of
people who also kind of claim to want to
understand the world
but also seem to
seem to be
satisfied by
obviously
insufficient answers right
um
and
well
part of my personality was
no we're not going to take insufficient
answers right we're going to look at
things
and
go all the way to the root of them like
what happens if you play this out if you
play this belief out to the end right or
if you play this idea of how things are
supposed to work out to the end and
i would say i was a little bit
overzealous in that because i was a
little too young to do that kind of
thinking but um
one thing i got very good at is
which was probably largely true
um
was just playing an idea out and saying
okay
this thing if you really look at it
already maps to this other thing which i
already decided is meaningless and so
this is meaningless too right and so you
can look at everything
and
see that there's nothing there for you
if what you really want is some kind of
you know
deep truth
that
um
that that will somehow answer this
question of understanding the universe
it is
it is very easy to look at things and
realize that they do not
that they are not
representative of that truth or
answering let's give some examples
because right now it's extremely
abstract i don't i mean the problem is
it's going to be hard for me to give you
accurate examples because this is 30
years ago right and so
i don't exactly remember the exact
thought process that i had this process
that i had it's more
i remember these
i remember what it felt like to be there
right and what it felt like was
you know i can look at any concept
and very rapidly
understand that it has nothing for me
and so i'm just in this void where
there's nothing for me anywhere
right
have you gotten over that
not a hundred percent
but
um like i said so the plan was just to
just to take a break and get
stronger and smarter and
develop somehow develop a view
that would enable me to
just be in a better position to ask some
of these questions right
um
okay so you're around 20 21 22.
something like that you
had aspirations of answering some of the
largest questions that there are and you
realized you couldn't do so
or the answers that were provided to you
were
you didn't find admissible it's not like
i wanted to publicly answer something or
like you know
win the nobel prize for answering
something it was it was just a very deep
interior
drive
right i just wanted to
like saying saying wanting to know is
not even right because it wasn't about
knowing it was about
wanting
like i'm here in the world
as a human being and like what should i
be
doing or what where should my attention
be going or like what is the you know
what is the point of doing anything
obviously i want the things that i do
to be
uh
in concordance with
something right or
it's just it's very difficult to
verbalize because it's very deep desire
that i had at that age this sounds more
about direction in life rather than well
what is the origin of the universe what
are the fundamental laws of physics and
so on am i correct or is that
are they related somehow
i mean they're sort of the same thing
right for somebody who feels this way
because
all right let's explore that how are
these
similar
for the
average person listening i imagine they
would think okay well the origin of life
or the origin of the universe or the
direction of time let's say the large
mysteries
that we have those seem unrelated to
what should i do with my life
so how are those two related well
what should you do with your life
right
um
either
so again you know as i mentioned i was i
was raised in
this
social
situation where it's like well you you
figure out the answer to that yourself
right
um
and so what
what is my answer to that is it going to
be a high quality answer or is it going
to be a low quality answer am i just
going to do whatever
right um there are some very obvious
things
even as a kid i knew i didn't want to do
so like do i want to go put on a suit
and work at a company
every day and like make money
and then feel accomplished because
i
have a
big title and a lot of money or whatever
and very clearly the answer to that was
no
right
to that kind of thing right
and so it's like well what is what is a
high quality answer what is a good
answer and
um
i just had this this feeling
that i needed to pursue
whatever was
actually true regardless of how far away
it is or how difficult that was
right and by actually true in this sense
i mean
um
well i don't know right right um that's
like part of what makes it hard
if you could if you could nail it down
very specifically like oh it's it's
purple and it's like you know three feet
long and two feet high
um
then maybe that's not that hard of a
problem
right yeah it's almost it's like a meta
truth problem some people say i want to
know the set of true statements the set
of answers but then you also want to
know well what does it mean to be true
does it mean true in an objective sense
so you can measure it and then you can
falsify it and yeah repeat it
i mean here i think we're getting to
there are places where language can
actually start to confuse things right
because we use the same word to mean
different things and often those things
have some semblance to each other right
um
like when you say you know what is the
set of true statements or whatever i'm
like okay
i i could imagine wanting to know that
but
that doesn't necessarily bear much
relation to what i was feeling at this
young age it was more like
um
like if you imagine
imagine that you had to like um
uh
like you had to make one choice and like
dedicate your life in some direction and
then you were gonna go that way
like that choice is final and you're
going to go that way so it's a very
important choice it's not really the way
life is usually but just imagine that
right
what is the absolute
most
important thing that you could dedicate
yourself to
that's what i was feeling
right
um so that's and to me like i associated
that with the idea of truth in some way
um
but
that doesn't necessarily have that much
to do with like the
the set of true statements where true
statement is defined as like
satisfies some kind of boolean algebra
you know when you substitute the things
or whatever
it's just a very it's different
um
although i do think it's not completely
separate like the the reason we call
this other thing
truth is because
there is a relation right right right
it's just hard to pin down
what made you go into video games
i you know i was just very fascinated by
them
um
even
it it's weird because these things
happened one step at a time and they're
again they're obvious in retrospect i
think also technology has been
developing a lot right and so from today
things look obvious that didn't look
obvious to me at the time so
when i was even like
seven years old or something i really
liked playing arcade games you know like
from the late 70s early 80s that you
would
those would be relatively common in
those days for a while you would see
them
like in
the corner store or whatever they would
have a couple
arcade games and i really liked playing
those and then um
when i got into the sixth grade so then
i was about ten they happened to have a
computer class at the school where i was
at which i think was um
i was probably a little bit lucky like i
don't know if every school had that at
that time
and um
but i i mean i guess i signed up for it
but but from the first day of that class
i was just really excited and really
hyped right
um
i just like loved being in that class
and doing the stuff
um
and it wasn't like i had this memory of
or i have this memory of um
i went back like in fifth grade
it was it was like going from elementary
school to middle school and at one point
i went back to visit my elementary
school and i talked to my math teacher
who was sort of my favorite teacher
there and i was like oh man you got to
check it out they have these computers
and you can like do all this stuff and
to me that was like
the thing that was exciting about math
but more so
but from talking to the teacher i
remember even at that age i was like
reading him
socially and i was like wait
he's not as excited about this as i am
he doesn't like understand why this
has the stuff of math but better he's
just like oh you know that's cool
so
i realized even then that not everybody
was into this
um but one of the first things i did in
that class was make a
very
stupid video game um it was actually it
was almost like a slot machine or
something where
you know it was written in the basic
programming language which is what these
were commodore vic-20 computers from the
1980s so you would turn them on you
could program them right away you didn't
need to like run things to program them
which was one of the things that made
personal computers of that time very
accessible
and
um
you know i'm i didn't have ideas about
what to make
but
i i knew that i could make something
simple and so it was a thing that like
counted a number up from like
1 to 100 and then started over and it
would say you know
stop the counter at like 37 it would
pick a different number every time and
you had to like try to hit it right so
that's what i was doing when i was 10
years old
now how did video games this let's say
aside when you were 20 21 you called it
a reprieve how did it aid your
understanding of the universe
so this is something that i've
this understanding of
this answer that i'm about to give is
something that i built up in retrospect
so it's not it's not exactly something
that i'm sure at the time but um
the the fascinating thing about games is
about video games specifically right and
so i'm not actually that into other
kinds of games like i'm not super into
board games or card games or whatever
which other people are um the thing
about a video game is
um you know it's running on a computer
at a relatively interactive rate and
even if it's whether it's it could be
running slow like a turn-based game or
you're marching a guy around a board or
it could be running fast like one of
these action games where you run around
all over the place right but either
case what is happening is
there is a recurrence
of
a certain
series of steps and the steps are
we read the input from whoever's playing
right or across the network or whatever
right we do some simulation which is we
have some state of the
of the objects in the world of our game
and based on the input plus whatever
those objects were doing which is like
the simplified laws of physics of that
game we go from the state of the world
at time zero to the state of the world
at time one right and then and then the
third part is we output that to a screen
and the speaker or something and then we
go back and do that over again right and
so
to
to make
uh
i mean
so there are different kinds of games
that
more or less
conform to what i'm about to say but at
least for certain kinds of games
to make them you're essentially
designing a smaller simpler universe
than the one
that we currently inhabit right
and
that lets you
maybe understand some things in a
certain way that that other people don't
have a lens on right so you know in math
or physics or something if you have a
really hard problem that you don't
understand maybe you look at a
simplified idealized version of the
problem and
you see something about it right
um and so
that's part of what's fascinating to me
about games there's actually
a few
part of what i've been doing over my
career is find these different things
that i think are interesting and like
put them together into one thing but
that's one of them for sure and so
the thing is um
if i want to write some fiction for
example and i want to say
there's a world and
it works
there's like magic or something and the
magic works a certain way
right
you can just say that
and if you're rhetorically convincing
then people will like your fiction right
but
the thing that you said about how the
things in that world work
doesn't really have to hold together
beyond some very cursory level of
inspection you just you just have to you
know especially these days people don't
think that much about what they see or
read in in the older days it used to be
a little more um
but you just have to pass that level of
inspection and then it's like a good
book or whatever
um in games that's not really true
in games if you want to if you want
things to work a certain way
you have to actually make them work
that way down to the core and you have
to come up with some consistent
system by which this kind of thing
happens
and
now now there's categories of games
where that's not true so we have these
like older you know point-and-click
adventures or whatever which are
basically a bunch of if statements for
the programmers out there but for the
games that aren't if statements for the
games that actually
decide what happens
by
simulating some state of some world
then it's actually a very fascinating
pursuit
to try to find
a way
to make certain kinds of things happen
um that doesn't
that isn't self-contradictory or doesn't
you know destroy itself right and
what you realize is that pursuit is not
it's not arbitrary in some sense right
like you
you don't get to just decide
what happens in that simulation because
most decisions that you would make
especially if you're inexperienced would
result in things that cannot actually be
made because they don't make sense
they're not consistent right
but if you
if you come to it with an idea and then
you explore how things actually work and
then you
use that to
modify your idea and aim your idea in a
slightly different direction and use
that slightly different direction of
your idea to go back and inform you
about what to explore about what the
possibilities are about where you could
take this system there's this nice back
and forth that you can engage in that
eventually takes you to places that are
very interesting
do you mind giving an example
um
well you know so to go to go back to
braid which was the first game that that
i released that was um
that was a big popular game
um that came out in about 2008 right um
a lot of the decisions
that i was making when i was designing
that were like how does time behave
right like this game is about
going to different worlds and time is
different in those worlds but
okay that's a very broad statement right
what do you actually do when you sit
down to make the game
well
um
and there's actually multiple layers of
constraints there's a there's an
artistic layer of constraints like
does this idea of how time should behave
fit with what i'm trying to do
aesthetically with the rest of the game
and then there's um
like technically
we'll call it a technical problem the
system's design problem of
um
how do you
like how do you
how do you make a system how it's it's
you have to keep stepping back from it
because you would think the problem is
how do you make a system that does what
i want but like i said that
doesn't work so it's like how do i
correctly engage in or successfully
engage in a process
where i start with an idea for a system
and what i want and iterate back and
forth on those things until i have a
final what i want that mostly coincides
with a final what am i able to build
that then
fits with the rest of this thing right
and so so to try to get more concrete
about it
um
it's hard it's hard to to give
because the problem is this permeates
every
every instance of decision making always
like when you're experienced and you
know what you're doing so it's like
every decision is made this way but a
lot of the decisions that i do from
moment to moment are so small that they
can't really be explained absent the
context of all these other things
um
like the examples that i'm that are
coming to mind right away are actually
examples more of
of something else that's more about
design
when you said that you had this
constraint so you want to play with time
and braid but then you also want it to
make sense aesthetically can you give me
an example of what would and wouldn't
make sense
uh do you mean aesthetically for the
last part okay well
part of the idea of the game
is not just
that it's fictionally
about
playing with time this actually does
kind of dovetail into the previous
question that i feel like i i wish i
knew how to answer better at that right
very great um
like it's supposed to be about actually
how time
is different
and it's supposed to be about
understanding the
interesting details that arise there
right so
you go from world to world in that game
and time changes how it behaves in each
world and
that leads to puzzles right but so
firstly the puzzles that you solve in
each world should have to do
with
the particular way that time behaves
there right like if i could do a puzzle
on world four
but i also could have done that puzzle
in world two
it doesn't really belong on world four
because world four is about
understanding this other thing right
okay like what the way time behaves
there right
um to give an example again to try to
try to be more concrete in the beginning
of this game
you learn that you can just
rewind like you would rewind a video you
can rewind your gameplay anytime you
want and that's unlimited
and then later as you go through the
different worlds there are different
elaborations on that so in the next
world you can rewind but then some
things don't ever rewind they always
just go forward right and and that gives
you sort of two classes of things um in
the next world
you can rewind but also even when you're
not rewinding
um
space and time are
like projected onto each other so time
passes as you walk this way and it goes
backwards as you walk this way right
and so forth like there's there's just
variations that occur as you move
through the game
um now
so i said puzzles
but even the word puzzle is misleading
because
the point of it isn't really to be hard
right the point of it is to
um
inspire
an understanding
of the thing
of the things that this particular world
in the game is about
right
it's um so if if the way time behaves
in in world four is that it
goes forward or backward as you walk
right or left
um
well that basic rule leads to
consequences like what
what are in the same way that if you do
some math and you start with a
particular equation and you can like
start factoring that and combining it
with other things to see what the
consequences are right starting with
that idea it leads to some consequences
right paired with the initial conditions
of these are the kinds of objects in the
game and whatever right
and so
those consequences are interesting and
the goal of a puzzle in this kind of a
game is to
illustrate a consequence in such a way
that hopefully
um when you've seen the consequence it
makes the puzzle
understandable and solvable whereas when
you haven't seen the consequence the
puzzle is not understandable so it's not
like an arbitrary
um
you know difficult to perform thing it's
like has an idea behind it right it
serves as a pointer to point at
a certain kind of idea
like oh
you know
when
when time goes backwards
um
you know
when you walk left well you thought you
had stomped on this monster's head
before
and in some other level he would be gone
and you could get past him but now
because you have to walk left to go up
here
he's in your way now you can't do that
right um that sounds very silly
like in of its own right but the point
of all of this right so human beings
actually
um
find this kind of thing delightful and
i'm talking about it in a very sterile
way but
human beings um
there is this well it actually it's a
thing about human beings um
we like to come to understandings of
things that we didn't understand before
and there there are many reasons for
that right
and so the art at least the the one of
the personal arts that i've gotten into
is
how do we
how do we refine
this way
of
setting up ideas and curating them so
that
people have
a rewarding experience having these
realizations right so it's not just like
how do we make games with tricky puzzles
and then you feel smart when you solve
them which is like
what i think is the
like through the game industry
generally there's some idea that that's
what a puzzle game is that's not really
what i do
yeah
so now why is that interesting or
important right
aside from well i mean if you can make a
positive time for people that
legitimately
uh
gives them things to think about then
that's
interesting right but then there's a
more you know tying back to
my desire to understand the universe
originally right
um what people do when they play this
kind of a thing
is they're trying to understand a
universe but it's like a smaller simpler
universe than the real one right and
it's one it's one that was made by human
beings and is therefore um
you know
less grand in many dimensions but
but
because it is embedded in our actual
universe it can reflect things from the
actual universe back at the player
and
that is actually very powerful
um and it can do this in a way that
other media can't really do or have a
hard time
doing right so
in in fiction again if you want to
reflect back
something about the universe
i mean you can do that like it's just
it's a different kind of reflection i
almost don't know what more to say about
it but but in this type of thing where
you have a system operating and evolving
over time right
um
like like in fiction you can illustrate
something that
might or could happen and you can talk
about generally how things happen
right like patterns like archetypal
patterns
well just i don't know you know
like
i just finished reading a novel where
you know
by the end there was a big war and it
went badly for the people who
you know
played a part in bringing it about and
and stuff right and
um and so there's this big human theme
about the way things play out over a
long period of time
um
that that's the kind of thing that you
can talk about in fiction right um in in
a video game
um
you actually
have things playing out over time
actually right
and so
the way that you can reflect
back
aspects of our universe
is
by actually
doing the thing that the universe does
as opposed to talking about it
and that's actually pretty powerful
right and so so to step back maybe i'm
skipping a step or two here but what's
very interesting to me about the ability
to work in this art form is
um not just that you're giving people a
hopefully positive interesting
experience where they got to
you know wrestle with
tricks or
puzzles that seemed impossible and then
and then they solved them and they got
this great feeling that they solved them
right it's that
a
um
you know when when people get all
spiritual there's certain kinds of
things that they'll say
um
and these are things like
um
you know like the the universe is a
process of change or
um
or uh
play like even um
you know ideas about about divine play
of form and whatever right
um and
the thing is when you show somebody a
simplified universe that is doing that
and i have i have to emphasize it is
doing that
because it borrows it from the bigger
universe that we're in
um
it can't do it by itself or at least i
don't if i ever knew how to how to make
that happen you could be amazing um but
you give people a feeling for that thing
right
for
you you let people experience a bit of
of divine play of
um
[Music]
of this
delight that the universe has in
changing one situation into a new
situation right
um
and
well and and if if you do that enough
right or if people do that enough they
can get a feel for this thing in a
different way than they could from other
places and i think that's
very interesting
with your puzzles do you try to make it
such that the mechanics of the puzzle or
the method that you solve it
indicates something thematically
or is it simply
while you're understanding more about
the mechanism of the universe so here's
an example in braid
there was the ring now i'm recalling 15
years or however long ago yeah so there
was a ring and
what i got the sense of was that it was
almost like it weighted you down in the
same way that some people feel like
marriage does that for them or at least
horrible marriages do that for them and
time
there was a spatial temporal aspect
where the closer you are to that ring
the slower time was
okay
so that
in a sense you could have done that with
any object you could have done that with
the box you could have done that with
the player's character itself you could
have done that with an enemy but in
chess you instead you chose a ring
because
well i imagine it's because it ties in
thematically
the theme thing plays a different role
than it does in other media right so
again if you're gonna go write fiction
or
do a film
right um
because you're telling a story
like the theme of the story is part of
what
gives the story
coherence right or whatever right and
and when we think about theme
in those contexts we think about
fictional
elements
that
cohere with each other i guess right
yeah
um okay
in games
when i do them um i feel like okay
there's a certain kind of storytelling
that
people in film
or people who write novels
already do they've got that covered
right i don't really need to do that
right what i should be thinking about is
what i can do over here that that their
media don't really do right or can't do
work or can't do or
maybe even are just 30 less effective at
doing like whatever right
so
um and that's actually it's a
fascinating process of exploration to
try to discover that because
this is a relatively new medium and this
stuff hasn't been mapped out really
right it's like in the early days of
film
in the earliest days of film
um
it was more like you're recording a
stage play and playing it back so they
didn't have this language of
cinematography that they developed later
about when they realized that they could
start cutting between scenes and people
would follow it and then that they could
even move the cameras and whatever
that that was a big
those were big steps in developing the
language of film which would be
impoverished without having discovered
those things right and so we haven't
figured out all those things in games
uh yet but in part i think because games
are so complicated it's going to take us
quite a while
to do all that um
so
anyway so to go back to this ring
example that you brought up
um
i definitely had
as part of the original picture of that
specific game
that there was this fictional like
brace around it that tied it together
but the
the gameplay
was the absolute core of it and the
fiction
like i wouldn't say it was less
important
to me
um but it was
um
like the fiction was something that i
could do somewhere else if i just wanted
to write fiction right
so
when it comes to
when it comes to something like the ring
um and what that where that came from
and what that is
um
those are decisions
that i think
um
i think i do this the way a number of
artists do where
these decisions are considered to be
very important
and they're also
um
there's some kind of very subtle balance
of many factors that tries to help the
decision or help
make that decision right um in this
particular case
well okay
there's a there's a kind of a right
making of things
that i don't think we have a very clear
idea of in the west i somehow absorbed
it
a little bit from some eastern stuff but
i can't even tell you what it must have
been when i was growing up or something
right but like
you want things you want elements that
harmonize with each other
to build something
that is more than the sum of its parts
right okay so so going back to
this time slow down effect
which is in braid um in world six
uh
well
the idea that i had was
you know i'd originally started with you
know physics concepts or something so i
was like oh well maybe there's something
like a black hole right time effect as
you get closer to the middle well if you
know any physics like what's the most
natural simplest shape of that
distortion right it's going to be
spherical or in a 2d world it's going to
be
circular it's going to be you know
radial with the intensity
increasing from the center and so if i
wanted to be like the physical world i
wanted it to act in that kind of a way
so
if i if i have the idea that there's
this world with this time slow down
effect
that effect is going to be circular to
be natural so i already have this
picture of something that's circular
all right so what should be emanating
this circular
effect probably something that's also
circular
well
what is it that's circular
but also
you know
embedded in this fiction
that is something about a relationship
or desired relationship between two
people right
um
well
so a ring
made sense and that's a sign of devotion
to a to a cause which is another element
of the theme and so there's a way of all
these things multi-dimensionally coming
together and making
like what's the right
what's the right choice
so that's really what it's about it's
it's not really um
oh i think this would be cool to add to
the story so i'm going to add this one
thing it's like it fits into this very
complex
webbing of
of stuff yeah so in that example you
have the property of time slowing down
then you're wondering okay well it's
circular and then what circular that's
related to this relationship and then
you also so that's one element that you
want to relate it to then you also have
some other elements which most of them
are probably unconscious but you have
other elements
are you consciously trying to relate it
to as many elements as you possibly can
and when you're doing this like are you
thinking out loud by speaking to someone
are you just writing are you going for a
walk
obviously i imagine it varies
yeah i mean broadly speaking what you
said about maximizing the connections
feels kind of right to me but not
entirely right because you can make
arbitrary meaningless connections too
and those aren't necessarily good right
um
so they're too contrived
yeah or they don't serve any purpose
other than being connections
or
or they're just about trying to show off
as opposed to trying to communicate
something coherent right
so
um but but in general
because because these things are hard to
do
then it's usually a sign of success if
you find a new connection
that
makes sense and fits into the scheme of
what you're trying to do right
those are the kinds of things that
are very difficult to think about
logically and linearly
right
because your logical mind is kind of
slow right you need leaps of intuition
to
get it to the right place where it can
then
keep going and and
solve solve the rest of this intricate
problem of how do you make this thing um
and those leaps of intuition for me
i don't i've i've never controlled them
right
they just they show up um
if i'm in a more receptive state
they might show up more easily um
definitely when dancing yeah um there's
something about that because um
you know it gives the mind a rest
because i'm doing these other things
um but also just
preparing
matters in a certain or not even
deliberately preparing but you know
sometimes i do a lot of creative work
and sometimes i do a lot of um
just
technical problem solving work that is
creative in its own way but not
the same way i don't think and when i'm
doing a lot of creative work
that's the time when i have more of
those
more of those uh
you know
um uh
just dawning of
good ideas that fit in and help right um
and other times
uh when i'm doing just a lot of
technical work um
i don't know that probably happens too
to a degree but um
not as much like i
they don't seem to need to be as deep
when i'm like trying to figure out a
technical system
you know
in the witness there are plenty of
what look like tetris pieces and then
puzzles where you have to
you have to draw outlines of some of
those pieces how are those related
thematically i know that you don't care
well
yeah is not the predominant factor in
your mind well the other thing is i'm
never gonna sit here and tell you really
what a game is about because
uh
first like i feel
it's not really possible to say that
like that's something that i felt from a
very young age and
it took me a while to realize most
people don't feel that way
um but it feels like
actually somebody was asking me last
night um
hey what
what do you think of this particular
director's movie or whatever and i'm
like
it's offensive for me to
say
what i think of it in that way because
it's actually a very deep thing that he
obviously cared about very much and it's
this
subtle you know multi-dimensional
expression and i i can't like what that
thing is i can't like
say
and so to presume to say it is
um
paying less respect than it deserves
before i even get to the point where
um
where uh
where i do that well or not right and
i'm not going to do the best job i'm
unsure about the example that you're
thinking about but is it with regard to
blame or praise
like evaluating the movies to being good
no i mean it's more about just saying
what they're what what are they about
um
why is that offensive
or doing a disservice to the filmmaker
or to whoever was the artist why can't
you say well here's what i think it's
about what do you think it's about and
then you have a conversation and perhaps
the artist intended for you to have a
conversation why is being silent
paying it more service than not
this is a hard question because on the
one hand it's very obvious to me
and on the other hand i don't
i haven't ever really tried to
articulate this with people so i don't
just i don't have spit it's all right
extemporize um
you're among friends the audience loves
yeah so let me relate this back to what
i try to do a little bit
because i can't i can't really speak for
other people of course other artists
making things
right but when i make something
okay there's this idea that i was taught
in in grade school
about fiction
you know like you're supposed to read
the fiction and you do your book report
and
um
what i was taught was that works of
fiction have
messages in them like morals or
something
and
sometimes they're buried in their like
secret messages that you have to
interpret right and then and then you
get it and then you can write it in your
book report and
these are overly simplistic
and the reason they are overly
simplistic is
they're overly simplistic for the work
of of many artists not all like some
artists
and this is actually very popular today
i would say um
like you know today a lot of politically
motivated things are written right and
if you want to write a work with a
political message
that can be stated plainly like
you know
um
you know communism is good or something
and if you don't like communism you're
bad
then you can make some fiction that
illustrates that and then you can say
that that's what that's about but that's
not the school of art that i'm in
and and that's really not the school of
art that a number of people are in right
and so the school of art that i'm in is
art is
like good art that is worth me spending
my time well okay i'm not the judge like
thinking your own art is good is pompous
right but obviously i'm trying to make
it good okay that's why you work hard on
these things right don't worry about the
disclaimer so i'm trying to make it good
yeah um
it has to be about something that i
don't completely have a grasp of
right
if i can sit here and say
uh
the moral of the story is always look
before you leap and that's what this
piece of art is about or whatever
um
that's
not interesting enough to me to spend
years of my life like grappling very
tightly with something and and trying to
figure it out right so what
when i make a game that's built around
something it's because i'm reaching a
little bit it's like here's a direction
that i find interesting and fascinating
and
there's something that's a little bit
beyond my grasp in this direction and
the function of art
is to somehow help with that
right
um
you know there's the old parable of
pointing at the moon and
you know i'm sure you've heard this one
right
um
it's
i i'm gonna butcher it because i don't
really remember it but um you know it's
it's a metaphor for
enlightenment right and
the guru is pointing at the moon
and
the initiate is
looking and seeing the the finger right
and thinking he's talking about his
finger
right and
so
um
what i'm speaking about now is is in a
smaller
smaller sphere of understanding and
grappling than that
um but
um
like like in some sense
if i'm gonna engage in this act of of
communication of of this
multi-dimensional putting all this stuff
together and giving it to you and say
here look at this right
um
it's gonna be about whatever is the most
important thing that i know to make it
about
and that's going to be about things that
are unresolved for me
in in
the biggest sphere
of contention possible that i know how
to
approach in any reasonable way and so
i can't even
really like if i were to sit down and
tell you like what the witness is about
i'm picking that one because it's a
bigger game than braid by like a lot
right it's got way more stuff in it we
spent longer on it
i can't even satisfyingly tell you
what that's about
because it's not really verbalizable to
me the most important parts of it are
not verbalizable to me so the best that
i can do
and when i say so
so verbalizable that's linguistic
communication right but then part of the
reason i'm interested in video games is
there's this other kind of communication
that
is about systems and stuff that i've
mentioned
and and that gives you another sort of
piece of structure that you can use
and so maybe you can put together enough
pieces of structure
to
go around the thing you can't quite
handle or point at it or
something like that right and so that's
what
these processes are like to me
um
so
how
you know
how am i ever going to talk about what
somebody else's thing is about if it's
if it's something that was
made in that
light right in that in that manner of of
action um you know if i want to tell you
what like avengers infinity war is about
like that's not very hard but i also
don't care that much about that movie
right
so
um
this is really
you know so so
i like a couple of david lynch's movies
really a lot right and so i'm not gonna
try to get an interview with them
actually oh yeah that might be hard
but but the point is
it would be extremely uh
inappropriate and somewhat
belittling not belittling because
belittling would mean that you
successfully diminished something but um
disrespectful and
not acknowledging of what is there in
order to
say
oh the movie mulholland drive is about
the following thing and write a
paragraph like that just doesn't work it
just doesn't work
sorry i feel like i've gone on about
this for a long time no that's fine you
actually remind me i was listening to a
conversation with you
speaking about art and i
have similar feelings with regard to
modern art i'm not a fan of modern art
i'm really not either
at least for me the reason it's somewhat
of
it's somewhat like carl jung reasons
although i don't know if he comments it
on modern art but he would call what you
he would make a delineation that
art that you described initially is
propaganda art so it's art following
one's own construction
and then the other type of art it's the
exploration of the unknown yes and when
i see modern art
it's
people making a statement and i don't
think art should be about
you shouldn't as the artist you
shouldn't know what it's about while
you're creating it you could post
post hoc come up with what it's about
but you shouldn't while you're creating
it say this is going to be about so and
so because
at least from one perspective true art
is
is perhaps stretching and finding out
where your world view is incomplete or
wrong or past
this domain that you
or passed your
or past your existing knowledge set
yeah i mean i think that if you haven't
if the
if the process of making the art hasn't
uh
developed you as a person in some way
maybe it wasn't that good
right
um i do think so modern art i don't have
much
interest in
um
or contemporary art i should say right
like um modern art means like a school
of
art that was a certain thing um
i like art museums turned into like
fashion galleries at some point and they
sort of became
so there's this element that has been in
art for all of history which is
here's an idea that was encapsulated in
this thing and it was an idea that
nobody had really
done before or had executed on it quite
this way
and so
you know
therefore
like somehow those ideas became
fetishized
and
uh to the exclusion of all else and it's
it's very easy to like
make a canvas or some juxtaposition of
objects that like
has some idea in it maybe the idea is
not very good but but that seems to be
all that people care about in
contemporary art now and there are just
things like
like skill matters
you know and i think that's been lost
like if you look at these renaissance
paintings of like
people who
obviously devoted a great deal of time
and energy to be able to paint beautiful
things right and then when you execute a
work
using the skill that is a result of all
that time and energy
um
it's devotional in a certain way it's
like
it adds to the
magnitude of the expression
um
you know it's um
like you've got skin in the game now
right
why do you think it is that now skill
doesn't seem to matter as much
well again i think because it's fashion
right they just want new stuff to put it
it's a social scene
right
um like most people don't really go
to
a contemporary art gallery
more than once or twice out of their own
interest right it because what's in
there is not really relevant to most
people but
if you want either to be in the scene of
people who are really into contemporary
art that's one function or if you want
to signal to other people that like i'm
sophisticated therefore i go to this art
gallery that's another function of it
but yeah i think it's actually um i
don't know it's not it's not completely
a write-off like you can go
into some place like that and find a
couple things that are interesting but
it's i don't think i have not been able
to find
interest in most of it right
and
for me when i go to a gallery
if i look at let's say renaissance art
some of it makes me want to cry and drop
to my knees and how
first of all gorgeous it is how much
mastery there is in
almost every square inch
and then if i look at
a piece of modern art it's as if
the amount of skill it's like
like i was saying it's more about the
commentary than it is about the piece
yeah and none of it makes me
want to weep let's say or think man that
it
sometimes that's creative and i like
that because
like i mentioned from you i like playing
with the form so i do like let's say
something simple like uh
a painting is meant to be seen at an
angle so it's a skew but it makes sense
because it's
so like if you look okay you get the
idea yeah so i like that but it rarely
evokes something in me
yeah i feel like we are we are in
times that are a little bit dark when it
comes to art
where
like the current educational
institutions right
have all kinds of reasons about why
our current
you know if you like i know some people
who i could get into an argument with
these things about where um
you know they have all sorts of reasons
why our current way of doing art is the
most enlightened right because if you go
back in history like this artist did
this to show this and that artist did
that to show that and all of these
things have an element of truth in them
right
but
there's this thing that human beings do
where
they overcompensate and they they take
things way too far right
um and i think that's what we've done
and we haven't
we haven't properly seen all the things
that we've given up including
um
really the things that make art most
beautiful like they've been they've been
abandoned and decided that they're
arbitrary
right
um so
what would be a better question to ask
you instead of what did you think let's
say you were speaking with this person
last night about a movie instead of this
person saying what do you think about
this movie what do you think the artist
meant what would be a better question
i'm not very good at how do you feel
no you know i feel about this movie i
don't like talking about stuff like that
after seeing it like at all
like i would rather just spend time with
people and talk about something else
well also because so if you're talking
about a movie for example
you know like maybe you go out to the
movie and then you go to dinner or
something afterward and i haven't had
time to sit with the movie yet i haven't
really absorbed it yet if it's good i'm
gonna be
it's gonna be occurring back to me for
several days afterward and
um
what i would tell you a month from now
about this movie is different from what
i would tell you now and maybe it's just
my personality i mean i'm not saying
that it's objectively wrong to talk to
your friend about the movie but
um
yet again it feels a little bit
like i the word that came to mind is
profane i i don't think that's quite the
right word but you know i don't mean
that in like
the modern sense of like the
expletives i mean it in like the monks
something blasphemous about it a little
bit or not not even quite blasphemous
but just just
spoiling something a little bit sacred
by just messing it up
um like be smurching it
yes
that's how i feel about it and that's
just my personal
thing and so i just don't like it
at all do you like hearing about what
other people think or you want to sit
alone with your thoughts well do you
mean about
so about movies or video games or any
piece of art that you experience
um
not really
it depends okay this is um
let me tell you the reason i'm asking
well for one i want to know for myself
is it necessarily good that i like to
talk about movies and video games with
other people or read about other
people's commentaries such as video game
reviews so one is a personal question
and then the second is i'm curious about
how you view other people talking about
your games do you not like the way they
talk about them do you think they
shouldn't and so on so that's my hidden
motivation
yeah i mean
those are
two different things
right
um
let's talk about the general video game
discourse one first
and i did used to
back in the 90s when i first got into
games i used to read game reviews a lot
um
and stuff like that but i wasn't really
approaching them
with an
eye to them
being a very serious art form in the way
that i am now that's like
something that happened
probably in the early 2000s like 2002
2004
um and in in some way
it was that attitude from when i was a
little younger coming back and finding a
home i would say in
my way of doing video game stuff it was
like oh i see what there is about this
pursuit
that
can be taken seriously and that if i
work very hard i can do a good job with
right
so
um
so at that point
i became more serious but but prior to
that point
i was just learning about games more
right and and i was absorbed in this
popular discourse and so forth right
but at some point
i knew enough about them and had thought
hard enough about them and had developed
my own
angle on them enough that
i don't find the popular discourse very
satisfying or interesting at all at this
point and i think there's a lot one of
those is maybe just
being older right like after you've had
so many decades of
talking about something
well somebody else who's many decades
earlier in that process of talking about
the things just is
that much earlier in maybe the same
process right and so
is there that much reason for me to be
in that conversation not not really
right
um
but secondly
like i have
you know this way of talking about games
and using them as ways of reflecting
the universe in
in particular ways
is not a very popular way to view video
games very few people
in the world see them that way
and the ones who do
might well describe what they do in very
different terms than i describe to you
and think about them in very different
terms right so
um it's kind of lonely territory and
when you live in lonely territory
um
you just see what other think people are
talking about and it's like well that
doesn't have much to do with me that's
not like i you know the people who
make a game like you know
call of duty whatever the new one is
that came out right um
like that's a video game
and it does even have some of the
properties that what i was talking about
but the company that makes that is in a
totally different business than i am and
the people who play that game
are in to some degree a different
business
than the people who play the kinds of
games that i make right not completely
right like people can go back and forth
and play both but they play them for
different reasons and
the the difference between those reasons
is pretty far and so these days
i do not
really pay much attention to what people
say about games even though when i was
much younger i did and that was
important in learning i think
now when it comes to my own stuff
i'm just not really
interested at all in fact it's a little
bit painful and the reason it's a little
bit painful is taking the example of the
witness um you know i worked hard on
that for six and a half years
right
and even someone who's smart and like a
good game reviewer or something who
comes along and plays the game seriously
for two weeks
and pretty much
plays most of it i mean that's such a
big game that very few people have
played the whole thing
they have two weeks of experience with
something that i have
330 weeks
thinking about right
so
you just can't
well and
you know lots of skin in the game and
like blood and sweat and the person
writing the review doesn't this is just
another game that they're they've played
along with all the others they have very
little skin in the game and so
it's this big asymmetry and it makes
things very uncomfortable
um and
for me i don't i don't really want to
read it you know um
because also
it doesn't really
it doesn't really help me in any way
you know
um
it doesn't
like i i know what's in the witness and
i know what's good and i i know what's
not good about it um but i doubt
i doubt that my assessment of what's not
good about it is going to agree with
what most people are going to write on
the internet
and so therefore
if my goal is to progress
i don't necessarily want to
look that way
at things
that don't have much to do with where
i'm going
right
so
with the witness i read a small number
of reviews like on the first day and i
was like yeah i don't need to do this
this isn't good for me first of all
and
it uh
it doesn't help me it doesn't help me
see where to go for the next thing
now is it that it doesn't help you at
all or is it that it's so painful to
look at that it would hinder you and
perhaps even mislead you because what
are the priorities of the reviewer
aren't yours there's both there's both
right so
you know there's all kinds of reviews
one kind of review is a commercial
product review
that's useless to me because i'm not
making commercial products i
intentionally make my games less fun
than they could be quote fun unquote
right um in order to support other
aspects of them and so if somebody says
this game isn't as fun as i wish it was
i'm like i know
you know yeah um
that's the choice i made when i decide
you know this isn't avengers infinity
war right um yeah i get that
so
that's one aspect of it now the other
aspect of it that you mentioned is
pretty interesting like there is
like if i work hard on something for six
and a half years and either people
dislike it because it's not a commercial
product or they dislike it because
it doesn't conform to their idea of what
the art scene
in games should be doing right now or
they just dislike it because they had a
bad time and it wasn't for them which is
totally fine right things that i make
are not
i don't try to make things for everybody
um
there is that aspect of like
personal pain sometimes like when you
when you work on something so hard and
you care about it so much
and somebody thinks it's
terrible or you just whatever they say
mean things about it um
even if i know intellectually that that
person is wrong
and has no standing to be saying these
things there's you know something about
the human organism reacting that makes
it
hesitant
to do
more things
that could cause criticism right
and i don't want to be encumbered by
that
flinching away from
um
whatever right because the next things
that i do
um
i mean i only have flawed human judgment
about what i choose to do but i'm trying
hard to make them the
the best most interesting most important
things that i know how to do
and that job is already hard before i
make it more hard by
you know
being hesitant because i felt burned
because people didn't like something i
did or whatever right
and
this is especially weird in the internet
age because
um
there's just so much more of this kind
of communication and so much more
amplification and it's just a well
understood phenomenon that the negative
stuff stings more than the positive
stuff
helps you right
um
like i've heard lots of
lots of positive feedback
from
people who
you know these games that i've made that
were very meaningful to them and very
helpful to them and
or inspiring or gave them ideas about
about things all sorts of positive
things that you could name and those
alone
all
certainly make it worth doing this stuff
but i still mostly remember the negative
stuff right
and that's just part of that is that
that's my job too like when i work on
something
um
going back to that conversation about
braid that we had before about
trying to find
the best
forms for certain pieces of the
expression
to take in order for it to
build into this rightly made larger
thing
that's hard and it involves actually
exercising acute judgment
on
the developing work
for years
and on ideas that come up that maybe
never make it in or whatever like oh
that's a stupid idea because it doesn't
do this and it doesn't do that etc right
um and my my personal critical voice is
actually
uh very
direct and
very uncompromising
um sorry your personal critical voice
toward yourself
yeah like when i look at something i'm
working on and like what do i think of
it right
and it's not it's not mean
it's not unnecessarily harsh it's just
like look here are the deficiencies of
this thing here are the things i wish
were better and
if you're going to make something good
you have to spend most of your time
thinking about those things
because
fixing those things is what makes the
thing better right
now
especially the longer you get into
development of something
complicated like this there's all sorts
of great things about it
that we succeeded at but if i just sit
there and spend most of my time
reflecting on all the great things about
it it's not really getting better
because we're not working on the things
holding it back right and
so i think you know we're in it
sometimes like
judgment gets a bad rap
you know like people think being
judgmental is bad and i think there are
certain kinds of judgmental that are
probably
you know
not good like being overly judgmental
about other people
when you don't know anything about them
right
um
but but judgment actually if you're
trying to build something
um
that
is very complicated and very hard to
make then judgment is actually very
important and very useful and actually
gives you a positive outlet
for that part of your mind and then
maybe it doesn't need
negative or less less productive outlets
anymore right
i hope
let's get back to that witness puzzle
question
about how is it that those tetris pieces
relate to the larger aspects of the
witness oh i forgot we left that
several a while ago in the discussion
when you were putting that together in a
similar way that you would
weigh several factors with regard to the
ring in braid what are you
using to come up with okay let's use
these
let's come up with a puzzle that looks
like so and so in braid and witness
specifically tetris pieces it was pretty
different right
the goals of the witness are pretty
different from braid
what i was trying to do there
i wanted
a system of puzzles where
you start out early in the game
and you don't know what they mean at all
right
and then eventually you figure out what
they mean without having any verbal
instruction right that was important and
so there is communication that's
happening through the game but it's
happening in this non-verbal way
um
and then
i wanted there to be a way
for these puzzles
to for the theme or the idea of each
puzzle to interact with each other and
create combinatoric surprise
uh and delight of of two different kinds
one like oh that's interesting what
happens when i see this kind of thing
together with this kind of thing it
makes this new
uh
it makes me have to think about it in a
way that i didn't have to yet right and
then secondly
you can use
the other types of of puzzles
to
build surprises like hey you think you
understand this one completely and how
it all works
but
actually
when interacting with this other thing
certain things become important or
salient that weren't before that you
didn't have to think about
and you realize that there's details to
the way things worked
that you didn't understand or or that
you assumed but they're actually
different from what you assumed right
and and so that's the broad canvas
statement of what's going on there
specifically with those
i was trying to do
something where
so the kind of puzzles you're talking
about they're they're all about
relatively abstract
concepts because they take place on
you know on these little idealized
puzzle boards you walk around this world
that has you know trees and buildings in
it and stuff but then you walk up to a
little puzzle board and you do it and on
that puzzle board there's things like
well there's little dots and you know
it's not much of a spoiler but like you
have to draw the line through the dots
right or
there's different um
there's different colors of things and
oh these ones you have to separate from
each other right so there's
and and the question was like what are
different relations of space that we can
play with which going back to this idea
about
reflecting the universe it's like okay
even
this simple idealized notion of space
like you have in these little puzzle
grids what are the kinds of things
that we can do
that like
what is suggested by
this idea of space and what what kind of
interplay can we have
in that
domain and so
um
with this puzzle area that you're
talking about
um
you know i'd had the idea of
separating things
so
this one was
um
sort of combining things
but in a different there's there's a
different thing that's about combining
things in a different way right
and
the question was
just how to
combine things
and it was just easier
in the game broadly you know these
panels you can just have arbitrarily
shaped things on them but in that area i
kept it to grids because
it's just easier to
think about and deal with and
because well
so again going back to math and physics
if you have two dimensions right
a grid is actually very
natural in a certain way right because
you have
when something is two-dimensional that
means there are exactly two directions
where going in one of those directions
means you're not going in the other
direction at all right there they're
perpendicular to each other is what we
call that in 2d or orthogonal in higher
dimensions right and so
um
like a regular grid is in some sense the
simplest way to divide
a two-dimensional space i mean certainly
if it's a euclidean space right
so
um
that that was just that it was about
playing with this idea and so the fact
that um
the fact that they're shaped like
irregular pieces
was just a way to give more
possibilities and more grit
to that there is of course a little bit
of a mental callback to earlier video
games like tetris right but but that's
like secondary or tertiary right you
know although there is one
fairly blatant reference
no there's one puzzle
there's one puzzle that i think of is
having more to do with tetris but
probably players don't really
in reality so
maybe it's not worth talking about um
but
um really that one was
had very little of a fictional element
to it right and just much more of a
part of constructing this system of
interacting
ideas okay now practically speaking i
may get into your creative process here
but do you have a google doc with bullet
points of all the different types of
puzzle elements like let's say this one
was shape delineation then another one
with apple tree is something like visual
environmental clue yeah and then another
one may be audio discernment with the
birds chirping so then do you have
spoilers everybody
so then do you have massive spoilers are
happening
so do you have a google doc of a or
whatever doc of a bullet point of these
are the types of puzzle elements now as
i progress through the story i would
like to include more and more of these
simultaneously or does that happen
unconsciously or do you not even care if
that happens
it's different depending on where
you are building the thing right in the
beginning i'm just like i want to find
enough ideas that even
are interesting at all right
um
and then
um like putting things in in a
spreadsheet or something is not a very
um
i mean it helps you list them and
remember what they are but the thing is
in games um
it's much better to just build a very
early version of the game and so that's
what i did like from the very i would
say week
probably week two or three of
development of the six and a half year
project i had some version of the game
where you could walk around and it was
really ugly
not much to look at
not much there but then if i made new
puzzles i could just put them there i
could program them first of all and then
put them there
by programming them you see how they
actually behave and whether there are
ideas in there that you didn't think of
right whereas if it's just written in a
spreadsheet
it's not doing anything so you can't see
what it does right and so that was the
development process was program new
puzzles put them in the world if i
thought there was going to be an area
where
where things might go i would just sort
of throw them on the map there and we
would put walls around it or something
and figure it out later
actually i think it's still up
we have a
blog that we were doing that whole time
and it shows
you can see screenshots of what the game
looked like
in this state when it was like very
plain and ugly and just i believe i was
following it back then okay
yeah so
um that was really the primary method of
organization of the game really
you know probably the art team when they
were working on stuff had probably some
spreadsheets and stuff about who
was going to work on what when
but
like that kind of thing but in terms of
the overall ideas of the game it was
just there in the game
and that's still true with with what we
work on now
why was it being non-verbal so important
to you
this is something like in filmmaking
there's that is don't tell but show is
it somehow more pure
or less pure if you are direct it's
probably related to the personality
aspect that i was telling you about
before where i don't like to talk about
some things like um
there are ways of
um
like speech is very linearizing right
like it goes whether it's spoken or
written it goes into a series of words
that then you listen to
and rebuild into something non-linear in
your head right and
that has a certain bandwidth to it of
what you how much you can do um it
actually could be quite high if you and
the person you're talking to have shared
assumptions about what things mean then
words call back to what those things
mean and help you build an l.a that's
that's why speech works right
um
but if you want to tell people about
something they don't already know
the the bandwidth is actually pretty low
because you don't have
things to refer back to that are
uh that are big and rich informationally
um so that's one thing but secondly i
was just really interested in this idea
of nonverbal communication and i wanted
to see what it could do in the medium of
games like is this something that games
can do
that they have a talent for right
related to other media and i found that
it seemed to be so
um
because in in that game you know
if somebody gets toward the end of the
game and they're playing some puzzle
that they're stuck on it looks
complicated
and you ask them what are you trying to
do tell me everything about what you're
trying to do if they start trying to
explain like well you know i'm trying to
draw this line to go through this thing
and around this thing but not around
that thing because with this thing over
here and if they try to explain to you
everything that
that they're trying to do
um
it could take five minutes actually for
for the late game right
um
none of that was ever communicated
verbally ever
right and and so that's very interesting
is an interesting study of what could be
done that way now that said then also
um
the
one of the things that the game was
primarily concerned with was this moment
of epiphany that i was talking about
before when you understand something
that you didn't understand before right
like
in a puzzle game when you finally are
able to solve the puzzle hopefully it's
not because you did a bunch of brute
force things and then you finally
accidentally
did a thing and it said it's solved
that's not a very good puzzle right a
good puzzle is
you didn't see something now you see it
and
now it's very clear
and
adds something to your knowledge
and you can use that
to solve the puzzle and move on to the
next thing right
so
i felt like a game that's talking at you
all the time
was not very helpful because part of so
part of what i was trying to do
was
okay at a very baseline just give people
a positive experience that has that kind
of moment of epiphany in it because
that's interesting and fun and
nice for people right
one level above that
um
can we create these moments of epiphany
from different angles on different
topics all the time to give people a
sense
of what all these topics are either
about space and light and shadow
and sound or about
abstract notions like you know number
and group and all these things
um
can we build an appreciation for that
right
and then maybe one level above that is
can we exercise
people's feeling of epiphany in this
simple world
that shares
a lot with our world
even though it's a simpler version so
this game has lights colors and shadows
and
sounds and our world has
these things in at least in human
experience
so
so
if we can exercise the feeling of
epiphany
well and from enough different
directions in the field of this game
can that then
give people something that they can
carry out a little bit
right
that
maybe in the real world they have more
of a taste of what this
sudden understanding is is like
and maybe that can be interesting to
them in some way and i felt like a game
that was just talking to you all the
time
um
wasn't good for any of those
layers right
especially
i don't know like if somebody tells you
how to do something
you didn't really figure anything out
right
um
so
it's a weird thing too because one of
the decisions that i'm still not sure if
it was right
um
was how much talking to have in the game
at all because there are all these
recordings um from various people that
are
the game is like laced with them but
they're kind of all hidden in corners
and stuff you probably have to be
deliberately looking for them to find
most of them
um once you know there's a few that are
like placed out in the open just to give
people the idea that these things are
there
and maybe it would have been the right
thing to not have any of those and have
the game be completely silent but
that didn't feel right to me either
even though it's more pure in a certain
way
and and the original idea of the game
was to have a very explicit storyline in
it with like a fiction and
things that were happening like a
narrator and and all this stuff
um and i cut that because that didn't
feel good either so
it's somewhere in this middle ground but
so it's weird because there is talking
in the game but all the talking in the
game is not at all about the puzzles
ever
right
and you have to kind of ask the game for
the talking because otherwise you won't
get it
um why was rupert spyro included
um that's a very long
i i don't know if i can explain that
very well from the point in the
conversation where we are
i will say
so he's in there
as
one of the videos that you can find
um
those videos are supposed to be
um
things so as i said earlier when i make
a game like this it's about things
that
i do not have a complete grasp on
right
um
and i wanted to return to this theme of
like trying to understand the world to
understand the universe and so
this is
i mean i really don't like saying
anything about what games are about
right right but one element of this game
right
those videos
um
illustrate
the process of understanding what the
universe is about from the point of view
of different people who have very very
different
views of what the universe is about
because i felt okay
if i want to talk about the pursuit of
understanding right
um
then
it's kind of a mistake
not sure how to say this in the most
effective way
um
it's a mistake to only have one
perspective and not follow many or not
be sort of like the temptation is the
temptation is to present yourself
to the audience as oh i have i have
answers about the universe and this
is how you will discover them right
and
um that would not have been truthful for
me to do that
so i made it
i made these things this part of the
game about
this desire that we spoke of at the
beginning to understand the universe in
the best way
possible
and so
you know these these videos come from
different directions
of understanding things so so one very
different video the the first video that
players are likely to find is uh from
james burke the english documentarian
and it's like a very um
it's a very like
pro
anti-religion
um
way of making sense of the world and
it's a very eloquent
like
well-presented thing right um
it's a viewpoint that does not really
satisfy me right i would not if that was
the way
that i thought about the world i would
feel like something was missing from my
viewpoint um
but
uh
very strong in in some other ways and a
very um
like in composition with these other
things
because that's what i'm always trying to
do is compose right in composition with
these other things together
um they hopefully
cover a reasonable gamut of
different ways of thinking about
the universe and
what it means that that okay and then
the other thing to say that all were
very personally important to me at some
time or another so the reason it's that
particular video from rupert
is because i was there in that room
uh that was
my first
exposure to him
so i was there at that event
and
um it was very meaningful to me like i
really um sometimes you hear people say
something and you're like oh
i
yeah
you know
so um
that's what that was and so all of these
videos have a very personal element
to them as well that help pick them out
from all the things because there are
many things that could have been in the
game to like make some kind of
philosophical point but these ones all
really mattered to me personally in one
way or another
one of the reasons i'm so interested
i was and am interested in speaking with
you is because we have so many
overlapping interests so one is this
multi-faceted
this kaleidoscopic
approach to understanding truth by
hearing other people's perspectives
especially those who disagree with or
that are so far out from what you accept
and
then i also heard you talk about stephen
wolfram which we're going to talk about
and so i'm interested in stephen wolfram
and his physics project i would like to
get to how you come up with your own
thoughts
it sounds like a trivial matter first
for most people like how is it that you
have an original thought but i think
that having your own point of view
is exceedingly difficult one of the
reasons i was attracted to initially was
hearing
you excoriate the general trends in
games
for example even though i'm a huge fan
of metal gear solid 4 and grand theft
auto and so on you were saying well
here's what i don't like about
so-and-so's story supposedly story
driven games in them whatever yeah you
had your own point of view so how is it
that you come up with your own ideas how
do you have your own positions
i mean i would say that it's not
automatic so
like i was saying earlier when i got
into games professionally
i would read reviews i would read public
stuff about them
and at that time i didn't necessarily
have
i hadn't come to many of these
conclusions that you're referring to
that i later talked about
um but what i did want to do is i just i
had a desire to be very good at this
right like i want to
design
the most interesting best thing right i
want to program the most interesting
best thing and that just
that impulse serves as
a motivator
to
just work hard on the things and
keep thinking about them and if you do
that
it always has seemed to me that i end up
eventually forming my own viewpoint
that's informed by all the things that i
learned right
um so it may just be an attribute of
time and
effort but i don't actually you know i
don't know how other people think so i'm
not sure that i could say anything
useful there
do you meditate
not as much as i should
but yeah i do so what type of meditation
is it mindfulness gratefulness
um you know i almost don't even really
know
what kinds of words that people use
because people use like even the word
mindfulness i don't know what that means
and i know a number of different people
who teach mindfulness and they teach
different things
so um or why don't you just describe it
if you're comfortable doing so well okay
i have training in a number of things
um
and they're all different right
so i have training in kung fu and tai
chi
i've done a fair bit of tai chi although
not
i wouldn't say it expert level by any
means
um
have been to a number of
vipassana retreats like the shorter ones
like 10 days silent retreat kind of
things
um
and i found those to be very interesting
and effective
and
a nice
like vipassana is
i personally find it a nice meditation
to be able to do and sustain if i'm
somewhere because
because there's an active component of
it
then
it's like because you're doing something
then
um
it's easier to not get distracted i
guess
that description may not make sense to
people who haven't done it but um
you know but but the most powerful one
um for me has been
um the kind of meditation that rupert
talks about and and that some other
people talk about which
may or may not be related to mindfulness
depending on who you're talking to right
um but definitely
uh just at at any time
you know
uh if i just drop into
a more
direct
mode
of perceiving and being
it's a very relaxing thing
and
you know at some point i just
found out how easy it is to do that
um
and it's been
it's been a good thing for me um
but but i but i can't so so the other
thing i'll say is i cannot claim to be
an example in all of these things
because
i spend a great deal of time
programming
had very little time meditating in
comparison so i i would not um hold
myself up in that regard
what does the meditation do for you
why is it important it evokes it evokes
calmness presence graciousness ideas
what
i mean i've always been taught
by all the people teaching all of these
kinds of meditations that they're not
necessarily goal
oriented
what i will say is
and also any goal that's short term i
don't particularly value anyway so like
oh if i meditate and it makes me feel
nice for an hour afterward
okay cool
like i like feeling nice but
is it really that important to me that i
feel nice right is that in my top
three priorities for life
not really
that's actually another thing that i
realized that i differ from a lot of
people on for a lot of people
feeling nice is in the top priorities
and for me it's not
so you know um but what i will say is
that there have been positive effects
and
it's just very hard to
pin
a particular effect to a particular
practice or a cause when you talk about
things that you've been doing
for a long time
um
you did mention on a podcast
that there's this one question something
along the lines of are you conscious
that you're conscious something spyrian
like rupert spire likes yes and that
from that question in one second you've
gotten some insights that have carried
with you throughout your entire life
yeah there have definitely been a few um
occasions where there are things like
that where like very very briefly
you know
um i happened to be in the right state
at the right time and
just got over something or unlocked
something
you know
um
that
uh
has has been nice
has been nice to understand or be over
or be rid of to understand that i'm not
bound by right do you mind sharing ones
that's
specific that you're comfortable with
obviously
um sure
uh this one is not
from that kind okay so there's
there's another kind of meditation i
know that probably is also
also some kind of mindfulness right it's
a catch-all word um
you know but it's a kind of inquiry
where you look
you you look interiorly to see
what's going on
right
um
and you know you're just you just
it's hard to explain to people who
haven't done this
what that's like but you just look and
you see what's happening um
and
i had gone to a meditation retreat
where
um
you know i'd been i'd been to a number
of them that that were doing this
practice and i had just i had flown back
from that one and on the plane back i
just
felt like i'd understood
something to a little bit of a further
level than i had before
even though
there was no concrete indicator of that
i was like i don't i don't know um and
then i just had good experiences from
then on like
so the next day it was i remember it was
saturday morning and i was living in
this place in san francisco
and
it's
you know six or seven blocks away from
some places to eat
uh
but the hill is very steep so i would
drive that six or seven blocks because
to walk up that hill with a full stomach
is like very bad right it's like a super
steep san francisco hill yeah um
and then i was like
i had just come back from this
meditation retreat and i was very grumpy
i was like oh my god it's saturday i'm
not going to be able to park anywhere
and like eat because it's going to be
all these people out for an hour
for
brunch ahead of time and like why can't
i even just get something to eat in my
own neighborhood what is wrong it was
like terrible right
um
but i realized so
you know we have all these stories
stacked up about ourselves and i
realized for example um
oh i have this idea that i get you know
grumpy in the morning when i don't eat
which is something you know not totally
uncommon a number of people feel that
way um
and i just had this idea that this was
part of me and this was part of my it
was because i have a high metabolism or
something even though
i was probably getting kind of chubby at
that point
um
and but
but i noticed that i was feeling
this way and i had had this training
into inquiring into feelings and so i
was literally like halfway down this
hill driving down the hill in san
francisco and i just looked for a second
at this feeling of hunger that i knew i
must have had right
and
just in in one second i saw oh there's
an actual feeling of of hunger there
like a physical
it's so small
it's like a tiny tiny pinpoint and it's
surrounded by
all this amplification to make a big
deal out of it and all this
amplification is made up and if i
actually just look at the actual feeling
it's no big deal and i could put up with
this feeling for a long time right and
so right there
um like it wasn't this big you know epic
i went to meditate for a month and i
came out in it was just one second in
one day i realized
that this whole grumpiness that i
thought was just part of my personality
was completely self-constructed and
fake essentially right
um
like you could imagine how that happens
maybe you're a baby and you're hungry
and you realize when you make a big deal
out of being hungry people bring you
stuff and that's or something like i
don't know that's just an idea about how
it could be
um but but in that one second while i
was driving down a hill uh
i just change that part of myself and
like
any time like i never really have had
the same kind of response just naturally
and any time that i start to
it's just like no i saw that it's not a
big deal it's not real like i i see you
know now that's a relatively
um
mundane
city like being being grumpy because
you're hungry is a relatively mundane
um
situation
but
it's probably
the most concrete one for me where it's
like oh i saw this ha i saw it happen
right um at the same time i think that
when you're engaged in these techniques
there are lots of things that you don't
see happen and there may be much deeper
than than that or
maybe much more numerous and subtler i
don't know about deeper deeper is a
weird word
um
but so that's like that's a benefit of
meditation right i don't have this
particular problem anymore that i hadn't
even thought was necessarily because i
thought it was a physiological process
right we we have these stories like oh
there's chemicals in our body in our
brain that make us feel a certain way
and like okay
i'm sure there's something to that but i
very clearly saw that most of this was
made up right
so
um let's explore that for a little bit
why do you think that it's made up
because it sounds intuitively obvious to
most let's say materialists
um if you take a pill that has a certain
amount of a neurochemical or can cause a
different neuromodulator in your brain
to be ramped up or ramped down then that
has an effect on your qualia
or your perception sure yeah so why do
you see that as
not being as
big of a deal as most people think
like okay okay i'm not saying that
you don't have biochemistry that affects
you right what i am saying is that
um i mean i'm not a biologist and even
most biologists have not gone and
measured their own processes i mean
nobody actually has a full view of cause
and effect in the human body right and
so we're guessing a lot of the time and
for me as someone who's scientifically
educated but not
biologically scientifically educated
right i'm making extra levels of guesses
beyond what a lot of people would and
it's like oh i've heard stories about
you know
how things happen in the body and then
well here's a way that i feel sometimes
and i made an explanation earlier in
life about what must be happening and
therefore
it's not really changeable like okay
for my biochemistry it must be
that
this happens and its cause and effect
but then i got some insight into the
fact that that wasn't that explanation
was not true right
um
it doesn't mean that there aren't
physical processes
right in the physical world it just
means
that my particular explanation was naive
of what was happening right
so
um
i don't know that's again i don't mean
to make too much of out of that example
because it's a very small thing but it
was just it was very concrete and clear
when you use the word story that this is
simply a story that one tells oneself
are you using that in a similar way to
this is a model that one has or are
models and stories different
i think that varies based on the person
i think for somebody who's
got it some kind of scientific education
then there's a model attached to a story
but the story also
to be frank about it um
it's pre-model
no i i just want to say um it's more
like the story serves as an excuse of
some kind
and then the model helps justify the
excuse
right
um interesting like okay
if i'm grumpy
uh it's not
it's certainly not a personality aspect
that i could change and be better at
it's just
how things are because of like chemicals
right um
that's an excuse actually
have you heard ian mcgill christ's
master and its emissary
um that i saw a portion of that uh
that interview you did with him because
it was one of the ones that i checked
out prior to doing this
the reason is that but but i haven't you
know i don't know the original word you
should read his book that's one of
a few books
that i recommend that's one of them
it's essentially you can think of it as
the
elephant and then the monkey on top and
the elephant is choosing the direction
but the monkey justifies that direction
post
oh yeah i mean it's very clear that
human beings do this all the time right
um
like we're in this time when
we
uh think very highly of
being scientific being rational right
that that the world is some objective
thing the rules of which can be
understood and then
you can
have an understanding
in detail of those rules and use that to
formulate the plans that are the best or
something right
now regardless of the truth of that
um
let's say you have 10 people in a room
who all say they're doing that
okay maybe maybe three of the people are
really trying to do it
but they're fallible as human beings and
so
all these ego things also come in and
help steer the conclusions right but
then the other seven people aren't even
trying the other seven people are
uh
just pretending to care about being
objective and going according to
principle and really are just doing the
thing that human beings always do
um
just
whatever they think helps them right now
right and and oh here's an excuse here's
a way that people currently socially
believe is justified
like we have this picture where the
people standing over there
are the people who are smart and correct
so i'm gonna go stand over there right
as opposed to being drawn to stand over
there by
a priori
understanding and belief in this kind of
a thing right
and so like that's as old as humanity
right it's going on now it's it's gone
on
forever and
um
and people will say that no no i am
standing here because of an a priori
dispassionate assessment yes but but
you'll see over time and and maybe
that's related to what i was saying
at the beginning about pundits versus
not um
you see eventually who those people are
um
i don't know how much that matters
because it's just
because as soon as you see how those
people are now you're in some new
situation where there are different
people
who you don't you know who you don't
know
so maybe you just have to make good
friends who you trust and go through
life that way
so while we're speaking about models and
rationality and science and using that
to
build up one's
world view or as i say veltan xiaohung
you you said that you were reading a
book called a new kind of science which
is stephen wolfram's yes they found it
extremely interesting i'm curious what
aspects of it
well because
it's interesting because in that book i
think he hinted at
the kinds of things that he's doing very
explicitly now
right where he's trying to
build a theory of the universe
uh based on cellul cellular i can't the
word cellular
cellular automata yeah though it's hyper
grass now it's like a generalization
and
you know that's a little bit related to
the kind of thing that i think about but
but in a different sphere right he's
looking at okay here's this certain
class of models of
what are essentially simulations where
they take in a state
at time t and they output a state at
time t plus one but if you're trying to
have an elevated view
t is not necessarily time because if
you're building this model you're
standing outside of the time that's
interior to the model
and you're just trying to understand it
and see what it does and maybe pick
design parameters
like you've got a large space within
which you can navigate by tuning design
parameters and you try to pick the ones
that give you the most interesting and
powerful thing right
so i think that's very interesting i
don't know like i'm not a physicist
right so i do not actually know
um
what his chances are of doing something
with that right um
and furthermore there's sort of the the
metaphysical question of
if he succeeds
to some arbitrary degree of
specificity in
reproducing
known laws and or predicting new things
i mean
of course predicting new things is
always like the gold standard of like
how you know you're into something um
but there's always the question of
uh
is this just one of a large number of
models that are isomorphic to each other
and because he likes cellular automata
he found the cellular automata one which
which would be a big deal anyway right
but it doesn't really answer the
question of like
our cellular automata fundamental or
something you know
um
although
like he probably has some angles in
which he would argue
that it does having to do with with
computational uh irreducibility and
stuff like that
okay speaking of computational
irreducibility okay wolfram thinks free
will is tied to that
i'm curious
but the way that he you the way that he
defines free will i don't think is the
way that most people would think
of the word free will being defined
more that you can't predict your own
actions it has to do with predictivity
either way do you believe that people
have free will
or do you believe that you have free
will let's say that
you're asking the hard questions today
what i think is that
the idea of free will
the question do i have free will
is
it takes as assumptions backgrounding
the for the question to make sense
it requires a picture
of reality that is too simple
and that by the time you develop a
picture of reality that is sophisticated
enough
that question kind of doesn't make sense
anymore
um i'm not claiming that i'm
at that level of understanding of
reality but i am saying
um
yeah can you explain to me the simple
background assumptions that go into a
question like that and then how with
more articulated assumptions or more
advanced assumptions that dissolves the
question i mean i i feel like this is
ground that has been covered
at least okay i mean i don't know i'm
often very unsatisfied by discussions
about about these topics but um
the problem is to do to do a convincing
explanation on this requires going into
a lot of like subtopics that
if people who who haven't heard them
before hear them first from me i'm not
going to give a particularly convincing
version of them because it's not my
shtick i don't go around
talking about free will but um there are
for example um things you can google
that will give you good starting points
so for example
there's a thing called
the the second time around problem right
which is that
uh
it seems to be
indistinguishable
whether
uh
like this is the first time things were
happening and we chose what could happen
or whether it's a fully deterministic
playback
of that and so that's a simpler question
that you could start with like
how would i even know the difference
between those two things because in the
first time around
so our
our reasons for believing we have free
will are the primary one is that we feel
like it right we feel like we have free
will
um maybe the first time we felt like we
had free will because we had free will
right
um but the second time it's a
reproduction of the first time so we
have to feel the same way or it's not a
good reproduction
but it's a deterministic reproduction so
it's not like we could have changed our
mind right and so
thinking about a simpler sub problem
like that is much easier than thinking
about the problem of
the actual whole universe that we're in
right now
um but by thinking about smaller
problems like that
you can broaden your horizons in a
certain way you can broaden the scope of
things
that you think about right
um
and so
in that second time around problem kind
of case it's unclear whether you had
free will or not because
which one of those are you in the
original or the replay changes the
answer but then it's exactly the same
experience in both of them so
uh
is that one experience or two
experiences do you even know right do
they like map to the same thing or are
they two separate right
um another another um
dang oh you know so for people who know
a bit of quantum mechanics right you
know that there are
uh
the everettians have become
quite well represented currently um in
terms of the way that people interpret
what's happening and
the way to interpret things from an
everettian standpoint is
that just
all things that can happen do happen
right
and so
what does it mean to have free will in
that case it doesn't mean what people
naively think determinism means which is
that only one thing happens and must
happen it's like no
actually a bunch of things happen but
then does it
maybe
like maybe the question of free will is
orthogonal to that in some sense anyway
because it changes the waiting on how
much of things happen or not like it's
unclear but so i think that
rather than trying to answer this
question directly of do we have free
will i think the best that people can do
right now is like go to the gym and work
out right
and like pump some iron get buff and
come back later and answer these
questions
um
do you mean that metaphorically go to
the gym
yeah but you know it might help
non-metaphorically as well um
so what do you mean metaphorically by
that do you mean go study philosophy go
live your life go
try and develop a skill
i mean if you're if you're interested in
the question of free will then
thinking about these sub-problems i
think can very quickly get you at least
to a point where you realize why the the
question as originally posed is too
simple to really make sense
but that's then been replaced by all
these possibilities of how things could
be are those possibilities fictional are
they real
that's sort of the material you would be
contending with
um in that domain but then
um
then there's maybe equivalent questions
that are something like
do i have free will but that are
um
more answerable and maybe more specific
right
okay we'll get to some rapid fire
questions okay we have so many audience
questions we probably won't get a chance
to go through all of them oh no that's a
lot
and this is
legal-sized paper
bullet points okay so one of the
questions so these next few are from me
i want to know if you've watched super
bunny hops review of the witness or
joseph anderson's review of the witness
no
do you watch video game donkey
sometimes
man i'm a huge fan of video games he's
very funny
okay what is your opinion on no this is
an open-ended one but please answer
succinctly briefly
what's your opinion on vr
um i think vr is very interesting
but not for the reason people think
especially vr developers right so people
think that vr is about
uh being more immersed in a game so that
it feels
real
um
and therefore it can be more compelling
or something and nobody in the game
industry seems to want to hear this but
like there is a little bit of truth to
that that immersion i will get back to
it in a minute about what's true about
it but it's mostly false because
when you're watching a good movie you're
immersed when you're reading a good book
you're immersed when you're listening to
music that you find beautiful you're
immersed like immersion
doesn't require you to wear a bucket on
your head right that's uncomfortable and
like heavy and all these things
now
the thing the thing that it does do
that's immersive is
you get a tighter feedback loop between
your propriocept deceptive sense like
where your head's moving and like what
you see
which is absent when you're playing like
a 3d game on a monitor because the
monitor doesn't move in response to your
head so
it it incorporates a little bit more of
your body and this is the more important
part i think um
just the tracking on both the headset
and the controllers
um
tends to be very good these days
actually better on the controllers than
the headset um
and what that means
is you have more bandwidth for
communicating to the game
right um in ways that are natural
because you know how to move your hands
you know how to move your head right and
you can move your body to move your head
around to change where you are and those
are relatively natural things compared
to
you know i'm using this mouse and
keyboard or something which is not
something
that came naturally to humans before we
invented it right you can learn it in
that way that we learn to drive and
stuff but it's it's one step more
removed and so
the opportunity of vr
is
to use this added bandwidth
um
in order to create experiences
that are um
better in some way defeat right so if
you think about if i'm playing a 3d game
with a mouse and keyboard my mouse is
like let's call that two analog degrees
of freedom it's even not that much but
whatever and then maybe the keyboard i
have like five or six keys i'm gonna hit
so it's like five or six bits
plus two
scalar numbers right
it's more like vr's advantage isn't that
it inputs something that's more
immersive to you it's more what you
output that the game can then use that's
the one that is the most overlooked i
think yes so you know just to quantify
again in
these are technically six dof
controllers because there's in 3d space
there's three degrees of translation and
three of rotation so you have like 18
scalars compared to two in your mouse
and it's not actually that much because
humans don't really use them
independently but it's still it's like a
lot more right
um and so
until now games
mostly talk and don't listen very much
you know like think about if you're
playing a game at 4k
at 24 bit color
at 60 frames per second that's like
a lot of bits per second coming at you
the number of bits per second going in
is like
several orders of magnitude less than
that right like way less
so
um what can you do when you have more
we don't exactly know because i think
designers dropped the ball a little bit
in this last wave of vr i think this
last wave of vr
would have like people usually think oh
it's because the hardware technology
isn't good enough um i do
think vr will get more successful as the
hardware gets better but
um i think designers dropped the ball
and it would have been more successful
if designers had understood
the opportunity
and taken advantage of it
you called it a wave
meaning that we're on the lower end now
yeah it's pretty clear at this point
that vr like okay so when
you know when palmer lucky started
oculus and then you know valve had also
been working on vr at that time and then
sony got into it and like everybody was
releasing vr systems
there was this possibility at that time
that maybe this is like the future of
all this stuff from now like it's just
going to be this gets better and
you know i think most of the people who
bought vr systems during that time those
are like in their closet right now or
something or they're not being used
daily right that's true for me and so
um
well
what causes people to get those things
out of their closet or you know what
what's the next system that does better
that won't go into the closet quite so
fast right
are you planning on making a vr game and
or do you have ideas for vr games i have
lots of ideas for vr games um not super
super deep ones they're just more like
starting points because like i said this
process of making games is pretty hard
and you have to get really into it um
and
we never really started on any of these
ideas so it's hard to say where they
would have gone but um
for sure
for sure
i see interesting places to start
for a studio of our size we can't really
make vr games right now because we can't
afford to because if nobody buys it
i see out of business right um that
might change in the future um but at
this time it's just not really something
that we could do
have you played the stanley parable
yeah
what do you think of it i know you don't
like to espouse
i mean the things that i remember the
most about the stanley parable are just
you know the character of the narrator
right
and
you know the way it's playing with
breaking the fourth wall with regard to
the narration and all that like all
things that you know like they're
obvious right but i think it was
it was a really interesting and funny
execution of that
um
all that was there so stanley parable
originally if i remember correctly was
like a free small demo kind of a thing
and then the bigger game came
substantially later um but i felt like a
lot of this stuff was nailed actually in
the original version and then the bigger
game just did more of it
i would say
what do you think of open ai as applied
to video games
i don't know like
i'm not really that familiar with
everything openai is doing like i know
you know they've done the gpt models of
you know language processing and then
people have found weird ways of applying
that to all sorts of things that are not
the original application i don't know
what else they're working on
i do think that
like that general kind of deep learning
neural network thing has a lot of
applicability in games
um
places that come to mind right away are
like making animations more believable
that's interesting stuff like that maybe
uh
making
voice synthesis finally happen right
because there's this thing where in a
game
you have voice you have voice actors
reading
pre-written stuff and if you're trying
to do a world like like fallout or
something where a lot of different
things could happen
you just have to pre-record a bunch of
lines but the actors can't really act
the lines that well because it's this
super non-linear space of like they
don't know what's happening right
also honestly
the
the procedure by which video games
record this kind of acting
is not actually conducive to good acting
so
the actors who are good have done a
really good job of like working within
that format to generate good results
right
um
i forgot where i was going to go from
there but uh you were thinking of
applications of open ai to video games
yeah i mean so oh so there's sort of a
trade-off right i think
if you wanted to do a game like that by
actually generating the text
procedurally and then having a character
speak it with like an ai generated voice
i think in the short term
that's not as good of acting
nearly as like if you have an actual
actor do it
but then again there's lots of video
games with bad acting and people think
that's fine
so
maybe you can make a trade-off where the
amount of stuff you could do in the game
is so much higher or the amount of
possibility space is so much bigger that
it's fine that the acting isn't
necessarily that good and you
consciously make that trade off right
what's your
thoughts on the potential of unreal
engine 5
do you see it as completely game
changing
um i mean it's doing
i i don't use off-the-shelf engines
right i'm i'm a do-it-yourself kind of
guy
um
part of what i value in having our own
company is the ability to craft
something technically that will do
exactly what we want right um
i think engines like that are useful for
a lot of people obviously um
with unreal i think that they're
they're
like
the stuff they showed off this year if
it was this year and not late last year
i've sort of lost
my remembrance of when they announced
like the nanite stuff and all that um
i mean i think that's just the latest
in
the kind of unreal engine playbook that
they've been following
since um
since the beginning really
so that's been successful for them
obviously right like they build things
that look really good
people want to use those things in their
games and so they license the engine and
this is
another step of that it is another step
of that in a time when it's harder to do
so that's really interesting like in the
early days of games
in the very beginning
it was just people like mostly john
carmack um
figuring out how to do stuff in 3d at
all in real time right but then once we
kind of had the basics of that
um
there was a great deal of like computer
graphics research that had been done
that was still mostly too slow for real
time but that we could figure out how to
incorporate elements of and and go
forward right and so we kind of had a
road map for a while like oh how do we
do
more complex reflectance models but do
that in real time on the hardware that
we have and that's a very concrete
problem right
um
now it's like
well we kind of caught up with
everything that's obviously good like
you know
something like a pixar movie does do way
more expensive rendering than we do but
it's unclear how much of that is really
conducive to real time and
whatever and um so
there's not like a clear road map
anymore like there used to be and so
if this is your job is to advance the
field now you're kind of striking out in
your own direction and so that's what
they've been doing here and
it looks like they've been doing that
successfully we'll see
i think there's some downsides to that
kind of model that they were advertising
um
just practical downsides in terms of how
do you make a game but
that's also what i thought when they
gave the demos
for what became gears of war i was like
i don't know how i would ever deal with
this and then that became industry
standard so we'll see
i was looking up some of the tech demos
on that night it seems like what's being
done is revolutionary and i don't know
i don't know what it is what that secret
sauce is that allows them to render so
many polygons
they've actually published some
technical papers that explain it right i
think they're so not worried about
other engines catching up to them that
they're just like here's how we do it
mostly because a lot of in something
like that
a lot of what makes it work is just that
you got in there and really figured out
like hundreds of little practical
problems right and they probably didn't
publish all those
because how would you right um
but yeah i think there are some
relatively in-depth explanations if
you're interested and now do you see
that as game changing outside of the
visual aspects like it's visual eye
candy do you see it as actually changing
the mechanics of the game or the way
that
either that it saves developers time so
they can spend it elsewhere or they can
use it to test
mechanically
yeah no design wise i don't see an
obvious thing that that does
um it's an obvious increase in the
visual fidelity that you could have in a
scene right
um
that said
like the way that they pitched it in at
least one of the things that i saw was
um hey your artists don't have to deal
with all these level of detail tools and
whatever
they can just
dump this source polygons that they're
working with into the game and run with
that and on the one hand that sounds
very easy right
on the other hand that sounds like a
giant pain in the ass because now the
amount of data that i have in source
control is like
several orders of magnitude bigger and
like that becomes its own
like i want to see what people do about
that right
um
that said it well and also it does seem
a little bit impractical for most games
just because it's a little too high-end
but that's the history of all these
things is they get built they get
announced
they're probably too slow to really use
right now but then next generation or a
few years go by and things get faster
and
then
you know so that's the same playbook
that's been going on for a long time now
that said systems aren't getting as much
faster over time as they used to um but
still yeah i don't know like i would
just like to see i'm interested to see
what they do with it and where they go
with it all right we're going to get to
audience questions
okay this one comes from forcefield i
want so bad to ask jonathan blow if he's
familiar with the work of henry berkson
the theme of the witness resonates so
much with his philosophy and all of what
jonathan said in in this interview just
underscores that i don't know why he
says in this interview
maybe i pulled this from someone's
youtube comment
so okay
so my understanding of henry bergson
this is funny because it came up
actually also in that other interview of
yours that i was watching um
my impression of him is that he was
quite prolific and said a lot of things
right and and
i don't know very much
i i don't have a comprehensive picture
of what he did um my impression of him
from what i did see which is maybe um
you know some long-form articles about
that time
combined with
i think i have a book of his and tried
to read a little bit of it is that i'm
i'm really not favorable
to the kind of things that he said and
wrote but that is a relatively ignorant
statement
because you don't know enough yet
because i don't i don't totally know
yeah it's just like
we're surrounded by so much information
that we have to early on make judgments
about what to look further into and what
to ignore and i put him in the to ignore
pile but that might be wrong right right
okay so this question comes from steph
how do you achieve subconscious artistic
expression in game making so for example
beethoven said that music just came to
him he channeled it more than anything
and david lynch said that great ideas
are like
big fish in our subconscious that we
have to catch
yes he may he wrote a book about that
called catching the big fish
it's very short and easy to read for
people who are interested
um
i mean i don't have anything to add
how is it that you allow your
subconscious to create
i mean i don't like if i try too hard to
make it happen then i'm trying too hard
and it's either not good or it doesn't
really happen right so i've definitely
been the beneficiary of ideas popping up
right
um
i have a speech that i did about this
topic that i could link to i'll have to
dig it up and
email you afterwards maybe you can put
it in notes or something
i i've been the beneficiary of this kind
of thing sometimes not as much as i
would like
and
um
it always makes the work that i do
better
when those come in
um
i don't
like if i could tell you how to do it i
could tell me how to do it
i do think that working hard on
something
is one of the ingredients
um
you know you can't just be lazy and not
care about something and get these kind
of ideas
you have to really care about it and
want to know aside from that
i don't know man
um
all right well we'll move on to the next
one steven brent says it seems to me
that you jonathan blow
one of your goals as a game designer is
to produce not just a physical response
in the player but to cultivate a state
of mind or awareness
do you think that video games are
uniquely suited for this goal over other
media other forms of media or
entertainment
they have their own thing that they can
do i mean we covered this earlier right
um
there are things about the medium that
we haven't yet completely figured out
that are ways of expressing
things that are different
from what other media
do and that doesn't just mean the way is
different it means that the thing you're
actually expressing is different you
know like if you read a poem in a book
that's different than listening to
someone say a poem it's very different
right
um
the the meaning that you get from the
thing is just different in each of those
cases and so games has its own version
of that and something later that comes
after games will also have its own
version of that right
and so
i don't think that there's anything
that
like it's not like games are better at
everything than anything else i think
games are worse at some things and quite
vocally have said that i think games are
worse at storytelling
than the traditional storytelling media
which gets some people very mad but i
think it's pretty obvious and
yeah um
however uh
that doesn't so it's
it's not like it's better than other
things but it is
its own
very useful direction at which to come
at things and
most of which is to date underutilized
right
maybe someday we'll start doing it in a
bigger
more powerful way we'll see
puja sony says
do you think video games can be designed
to cure mental illness
such as being implemented as therapy
as said no
right
um
like i don't know very much about
actual mental illness right so i'm not
about to prescribe any way of dealing
with it
i think a game could be an ingredient in
something but i should certainly
for the foreseeable future if i were to
plan some regime of how to deal with
this i would say you want somebody
to talk to who's very competent in
dealing with mental illness and who has
a lot of experience and who can make
uh very informed and very likely
beneficial choices about how to deal
with it and then among the choices that
that person picks
maybe there could be some game
approaches in there
right it's not like it's not like you
could play a game
that acts like a pill that you take that
would cure mental illness that's just
not gonna be a thing yeah it seems clear
that some video games for many people
are therapeutic they say this game got
me out of my depression this game helped
me see so-and-so from another
perspective oh yeah that was a thing i
want to say though too sure
um
they definitely can be very beneficial
before you get to the point of mental
illness right
um if if you were in danger of having
some kind of a spiral downward or just
even in making people's lives better
however
we don't really use them that way
and actually a lot of
games i think are net negative maybe
most games in that
they seem fun they seem interesting they
seem compelling and and maybe they are
those things in the short term
but they cause you to make trade-offs
that are bad in the long term right and
that make you un less happy in the long
term
right so if you just sit there playing
like world of warcraft every day for 10
years
was that really a good thing to do i
have to advise people against things
like that it doesn't seem very good to
me right
it sounds similar to social media where
initially could be connecting connecting
you with your family and your friends
but then
maybe in week one even it becomes
destructive and becomes habit-forming
yeah i mean there are many things in
life like that but i think
once we unpacked computers and software
we like discovered a whole bunch of new
ones right
social media is definitely one
um social media probably more dangerous
than video games right video games get a
bad rap but i think social media
is worse
um
but but games you think it should be
regulated
i don't know maybe
um
sorry if i'm putting you on the spot
it's just i'm curious no no no no i just
i don't know what i think with regard
because broadly speaking
i think we have way too much regulation
right now in too many places that are
unhelpful that doesn't mean there isn't
regulation that could be made that would
be helpful in specific places like so on
net
i think we need to delete a lot of laws
um
but maybe that's a place where we could
have some i don't know
um
yeah all right
james r
wants to know what are his thoughts on
mind uploading digital consciousness and
such ideas
i think those ideas
are
again they're
we're in this world
where people get excited about ideas
like that that haven't been fully
thought out
all right so similar to the free will
question being simplistic yes it's too
simple so so let me let me at least say
why so that people don't get mad um so
uploading your brain into a computer
right and then you're supposed to be a
conscious dude who like walks around and
does all sorts of cool stuff inside the
computer all right well
that implies
that
thinking is what
makes you conscious because that's like
the computer would be doing simple
manipulation we already know that's not
true and in fact anyone who's
been done any successful meditation at
all for even like a minute
knows that thinking is not what makes
you conscious thinking is a thing that
you're conscious of right
so
you have to be talking about
replicating something besides the
thinking part that's actually the vast
majority of your experience okay so
that's part a part b
um
if that is suddenly conscious why why
are other things that computers are
already doing not conscious they're
pretty complicated
right um and if something a computer
does can be conscious
um
why
like what's a computation do you even
know like i actually don't understand to
this day what a computation is right i
still am trying to understand that and
so
there's this rhetorical magic doing a
lot of work where like oh if a computer
is computing things and simulating you
then that simulation will be conscious
and it's like
if that's true
then it has some implications that you
haven't thought about
that maybe other things are conscious
that you don't think are conscious or
that maybe
um
you know maybe maybe material has
aspects to it
if you have a materialist view maybe
material has aspects to it that you
haven't considered right and so
um it's i don't want to try to make the
full complete case here for that because
i haven't
prepared it or thought about it lately
um but i i will say one of the speeches
that i gave a
private version of a year ago that i
want to give a full version of is um you
know one version of this is the
simulation argument is has been pretty
popular among people who
who talk about stuff and that is like oh
if you do the math it's actually likely
that we're living in a simulation right
now that's in a computer right and so
therefore of course you could simulate
yourself in another computer because you
already are in one and like
i think that argument is basically
meaningless and i can make a pretty good
case
as to
why it doesn't actually mean anything
but it probably takes an hour to make
that case
or more or two hours
yeah the next question comes from tom
this is quite long but most of it is
plotted thank you kurt for arranging
this interview a very pleasant surprise
which has motivated me to comment for
the first time
thank you mr blow for your willingness
to be interviewed here are my two
questions what further insights into the
tension between the analytical and
rational versus intuitive slash supra
rational mindsets presented in the
witness have you seen
have you had since its initial release
okay wait let me think about how to
yeah please reread the sentence at least
what further insights into the tension
between the analytical mind and the
intuitive mind
presented in the witness have you had
since its initial release
i i mean i understand the question i
would say that i don't
break it down that way for myself i
understand so that is um
that is a dichotomy
that we toss around
like our society has tossed around and
has found to be useful in thinking about
things sometimes
it's not really the way i thought about
what i was doing there
necessarily or
maybe it's a little bit related but
but again
um i wouldn't be satisfied by thinking
about things in that way
yeah okay then his second question is
have you heard of jonathan pagel's work
concerning symbols understood as basic
structures of reality
um i've heard of it i'm not familiar
with the actual work
yeah he said i would like this is the
end of it it's not a question i would
like to kindly ask you kurt to send my
and many other people around here
warmest regards to mr blow and
well that's great it's always nice to
hear you know like
we work so hard on these things
you know it's it's always good to hear
when
when they actually do something for
someone
chris marola any puzzle games in the
past 10 years that you loved
well um so right around the time the
witness came out a couple months later a
game came out called steven sausage roll
which sounds like a very silly name
it really is one of the best puzzle
games ever made and
i recommend people play it
i i don't want to spoil anything i can't
tell you why
you may bounce off it it's pretty hard
but if you're interested in puzzle games
it's amazing
i got to play it actually
before uh the witness came out because i
was playing a pre-release version and i
had this feeling like wow this might be
better than the kind of stuff that i'm
doing
that's i mean that's
pretty amazing to see
but also worrisome it's like oh man is
this thing that i'm working on gonna
actually be good um
there's some other games that came out
since
since then um
i mean i really like those actronics
games which are kind of puzzly they're
kind of a lot about programming
there's one particular game of his
called opus magnum that i think is very
approachable
um
so
you know um
you just said
man i don't know if my game will be any
good now when you say that what are you
referring to as being good is it if
people enjoy them is it if people like
that's an overstatement because
like
the feeling was more it's an
oversimplification because i knew it was
good right
um
for my you know again for my metric of
what's good um but
um
there there's a certain uh
way
that we went into at length before about
going into a possibility space of a game
of like what how things work and
discovering what can happen
from that and and finding the best
things and giving them to the player
right and
um
i had done a bunch of talks where i
discussed that process but i hadn't
really seen much in the way of other
games that did that and steven sausage
roll actually does that
um
and
it's just an amazing game you know
very happy that i got to play it so
it does that in a different way i would
say than the witness did and so
it was like wow
somebody else is doing the same kind of
a thing um
whereas i thought i was sort of the only
person doing it i guess is the feeling
right so
it's a good feeling because you don't
feel as alone anymore
have you reached out to the developer
oh um i mean he sent me a pre-release
copy so you know he's someone who i've
never met in person but you know knew
about and we'd corresponded and stuff
champion chap asks i seem to remember
john saying he has fantasia
could you ask him
if he if well if he does and does it
show in the game design
um
yes we'll define for the people out
there
this is something it's a relatively new
concept i think from the past couple
decades
um
uh but the idea is
um
some people
when they close their eyes and you ask
them to visualize something they
actually see a picture of some kind i do
not
i don't
um it's not that i can't because i have
in rare occasions seen quite vivid
mental pictures but from day to day i
simply don't have a picture
of anything
does that show up in the design i don't
know i mean
probably in some way because it's part
of
who i am and
things that i do are a product of who i
am but not in any direct obvious way
brian mauch asks
ask why the industry has gone to [ __ ]
and why studios and publishers are
comfortable releasing unfinished games
full of bugs
at full triple a prices
because they can because people can buy
them but also games have legitimately
gotten harder and harder to make
because they're so complicated and
so expensive
i
you know with my programming language
stuff i'm working on one axis of that
where i'm i'm trying to make the
technical part of game creation less
insane
and
and just more
simple and robust and easy to deal with
that seems to be succeeding but who know
like having a programming language be
adopted by the world is like a whole
thing and who knows if that will happen
um
also the thing to say is that people
have been saying some variation of that
the entire time i've been in the games
industry right it used to be
aaa games are so unimaginative and
uh
you know don't don't do anything
creative
um
that's actually still true right um
it used to be well there was a time when
it was that they were super buggy when
we were first starting to do 3d
uh because it was so hard and then we
kind of figured it out and they became
less buggy for a while but now they're
more buggy again because they're more
complicated um
i'm not sure that games are uniquely bad
in that respect now it's just aaa doing
their thing
as they have
james jones asks do you have any ideas
on using neuralink or any other brain
software interfaces in the future
no i mean with that kind of thing
what you have in your mind right now is
like what you imagine it might be like
you don't know what it's going to be
like right and you can't design for
something unless you know what it is so
we just have to see
okay ein ethne says oh exciting as i'm a
software engineer question for him do
you use machine learning and or ai
development when working on game design
and development if so how
uh not on any current projects there's
one that we were doing um
for a little bit but
it turned out we were working on too
many things at once so that's on pause
right now but we were using it to
try and generate
facial animation from uh vocal tracks so
a little bit the opposite of what i was
talking about before but like if you
have a voice actor read some lines
and it's well acted and all that stuff
now you want the character on the screen
to like say the lines and have their
face move in the right way there's
historically you might try to record
that by having the actor like wear all
this stuff
and then
you know but but there's a lot of
drawbacks to that
so we were like hey can we just generate
the animation and we had uh some
beginning of that but we hadn't gotten
very far before we pushed pause on the
project
there's this great youtube channel
called two minute papers
do you subscribe to it
no but i've seen a couple of them i
think man like every week or so it makes
me wonder man the implications of this
for game development but it's also like
you hear about there's a pill that works
in rats such that they can eat as much
food as they want and they don't get
fat and then you then you wonder well
man that'll be great once it comes to
humans and then it does way too long
yeah
okay so this guy
this guy named
johannes norbaca from a programming
language designers perspective
where jai has been described as
data oriented
what is his opinion on other data
oriented languages like erlang elixir
clojure
and
in context to that what languages
virtual machines and paradigms inspired
you while you were designing jai
so how does it compare contrast to other
data oriented all those languages
mentioned seemed very different to me so
and and i
some of them i know more about how they
work than others so i i find it hard to
make a statement that crosses all of
those um
i also would say i wouldn't necessarily
say data oriented is
the motivator behind what i'm doing i
think it's
compatible with a data oriented approach
but i wouldn't say that that's
the lens from which it's being designed
um
in terms of inspirations
it's going to be hard to say this in a
way that's going to be taken correctly
but like
lisp and
standard ml of new jersey which is like
a later functional language that i used
in the early 90s um
our inspirations but not in any obvious
way because the way this language works
is nothing like the way those work but
um
like lisp especially was a messy
programming language that was pretty bad
in a lot of ways like there's a lot of
lisp evangelists that say like oh it's
great it's actually pretty bad in a lot
of ways but it had some things about it
that were really good and that never
really were reproduced
at least certainly not in systems
languages like c
and
the failure to reproduce those things
has led to a lot of practical problems
today
so for example in in any interpreted
language so even like python today or
something but going back to lisp
you don't need to have a build process
to know what the program is it's just
like whatever file you load first loads
some other files
and then it starts running because it's
an interpreted language and so
your program defines itself in that way
right whereas in languages like c and
all the languages that came down from c
that's not true you like need an entire
at least one probably multiple
programming languages outside your
original language to say what the
program is to define what all the files
are and how they get put together
and that's a very severe deficiency
actually but nobody seems to take that
deficiency seriously but we all suffer
from it all the time so um
it's things like that it's like okay
let's do a systems language but let's
take this good part about lisp that we
figured out in like freaking 1965
right and actually bring that to these
languages
um
yeah
laura labu wants to know what connects
him for what connects you john to
non-dualist teachers like rupert spyra
what connects me i mean aren't we all
connected right
um
i mean is
you know i i ran into rupert's teachings
somewhere and i resonated
with them quite well
um
i don't know i don't know what more i
don't know why it resonated with you
well
i wouldn't even say that i just would
say
um
it's very hard to say things about this
without feeling like i'm telling people
what they should do or what they should
resonate with or
etcetera right it's your own opinion
yeah i mean i think all of us are drawn
to things and
you know
repelled by other things
um
i wouldn't say
however
like sometimes the impulses that draw us
to something are
impulses to be respected and paid
attention to and sometimes those
impulses are like
you know
shallower and
maybe things that we would be better to
do without right and so
um so i don't think like it's a very
contemporary statement to say oh well
people just like different things and
it's all equally good i don't think it's
actually all equally good
um
and i think that this idea that it's all
equally good is kind of part of why
society we're at a stagnant point right
now
um but all that said
i it is a rather personal thing
what
what
makes sense to me and what resonates
with me and
um
to try to project that on onto other
people i don't think is my job and so if
i make a game that
deals with material like this it's a
challenge to do that without attempting
to
throw throw it at you
so that it tries to stick or something
right that's not
you know it's a different thing it's
like oh you're not trying to
indoctrinate anyone or nor do you want
it to feel like that yeah it's just like
hey
look at this thing and
if you want to
and maybe there's an opportunity for you
to have
some kind of feeling like i had in the
process of encountering this material
but maybe not right and if not that's
cool but if so that's great
right and so
maybe we've gone far afield from the
original question but
that's how i feel about it
you also mentioned that this insistence
that there is no
skill or competence or that we're all
equal in some manner is one of the
reasons why we're at a societal
stagnation point okay so firstly what's
meant by this stagnation and then how is
it
drawn from this insistence on equality
of skill or merit and so on
okay so to go back to that insistence
it comes from something that's true
originally and it's just over
extrapolated right the thing that's true
is that
you know we're all born here and none of
us is better than anybody else and
we're all equivalent to each other in
some way right there but for the grace
of god go i kind of realization right um
but that doesn't mean you can't make bad
choices and that doesn't mean that
in fact
i mean okay see when you talk start
talking about spiritual stuff
um
let me just
when you start talking about spiritual
stuff
you almost can't say anything because
what even what i just said is not
actually true that you can't
of course you can't make bad choices
um it's actually not possible to make
bad choices but
if you go to the world
of human beings just trying to do human
being life stuff then you can make bad
choices right so
um
we we somehow have a society where
we kind of want to think that that's not
true like if somebody
if somebody ends up in an unfortunate
place it's because of the forces that
were acting on them right they were
under privileged and had a bad
you know
were under you fell into the undertow of
society whatever right
and all that is true
to some degree
but at the same time
if
if we don't have
this idea that people are
also responsible for themselves
there's no energy to go to a good place
that comes from anywhere right
so if you want to go to a good place
there are some
attitudes
that are much more conducive to that
than other attitudes and i think
we've got some attitudes that
don't help and
you know personally
i see this at all levels of society so
like if you look at people who are the
experts in various things
or who
uh who are the societally um
designated experts like the people who
have the degrees
the people who have the positions in
government and whatever i don't think
most of those people are very good at
what they do there are occasional
outliers right but for the most part
it's just we set up a system of how do
you rise in the ranks of these various
things
um
those systems were founded
originally
in ways that were functional
you know like like originally having a
phd was a really big deal right
now it's
well and when we set up that system
it was a system to help with that kind
of learning and discovery of new
knowledge now getting a phd is basically
filling out a tax form
but
it takes four or five years
not for everybody some people do phds
that are actually
closer to the spirit of what the
original thing was but we've kind of
slowly over time replaced the original
thing with this other thing that is
actually quite different right
and
produces different output and
um
you know
there are consequences to that i think
and
that's all i mean we're getting into
like personal rants at this point
um
that's but that's that's how i feel
about it
mr k wants to know what the f is going
on what the f is kojima working on i
have no idea i live in the us he lives
in does he still live in japan or did he
move i don't think so i think he's in
america now okay well that shows you how
much i know kojima production on there
yeah
xenoevil says i suppose the main
question i have is why he thinks the
success of braid didn't lead to more
copycat games it's still pretty much one
of a kind
okay actually
there sort of were copycat games
but in a different way and
because the motivation was different
right so
as we discussed
when doing braid
part of the motivation was an
exploration of the universe in like how
do you
make a little mini universe that has
these fascinating aspects that in some
way reflects the big universe back at us
in an interesting way right
what the game is taken to be by a lot of
people who play it
as well as many people who would want to
copy it is like well it's a fun
platformer game and it's got some trippy
time stuff which is true actually right
but the goal wasn't exactly to do trippy
time stuff you know
um
if you start to make a game and your
goal is to do trippy time stuff which
you might do if you were going to make a
copycat game there's a lot easier ways
to do it because it's actually pretty
hard to program the system that has all
these different time behaviors that all
mesh in the same
simulator it's much easier to like make
a game where the fiction is about time
travel because anybody can write a story
about time travel right
and then um
maybe we'll have some animated scenes
that you can make the animation go
backwards and it looks cool like
there's a castle that's destroyed and
you press rewind and it undestroys
itself and that looks cool right there
are definitely a number of games who
have done stuff like that
um
and those things are just a lot easier
and
there's no need to do the hard thing if
you're just trying to make money or
whatever would be your reason or even if
you're just trying to do something that
looks cool
these games do the thing that looks cool
right um so
uh
yeah there i i'm not aware of any game
that is a copycat of braid in the deep
sense and i think it's just because
there's easier things to do
okay this person wes lord wants to know
it i'd love to hear more about john's
past struggles and with burnout and
motivation and his approach to getting
work done how his approach to getting
work done has changed
i mean i have a whole speech about that
that i can link you to as well all right
please do okay
um
you know in terms of individual
motivation i'll say one other thing
which is
i mean obviously this was a very short
question and i don't know the
questioner's background and all these
things but a lot of the time i get a lot
of questions these days by like
people who are asking how how do you do
a lot of work or how do you get started
and all that and
very often these questions
are themselves a procrastination
right it's like
obviously i'm in the state where i can't
do
a lot of work right now so i need
somebody to give me the answer before i
can
and actually the secret is you sit down
and decide to do it
that's all it is right
um
seinfeld is like that that's his famous
advice to comics to comedians um yeah
comedians always want to know what's the
secret he says just work stop talking
about it yeah
because that's it's like oh
someday i have permission to not
actually do this work until someday
somebody bestows upon me the magical
you know i don't know baton from olympic
baton right it's that's not how it is
it's like you make a baton and run with
it that's that's actually how it is and
so um
now
it might be that
people
don't want to work that much on
something maybe they don't actually
think it's as important as they would
like to think it is right like what you
intellectually think should be important
versus how you actually respond to
things is very different and you might
have a a mismatch there um
maybe you there's nothing that's
important enough to you yet maybe you
haven't discovered that and so
maybe you go to the gym and work out for
a while right
um
yeah that's probably enough on that
topic bc one and zero many people have
said some similar sentiments please beta
access to jai i will pay 100 for access
we're you know we're working on rolling
it out wider it's been um
so one of my goals
in doing this language has been to solve
problems that
are happening with the way things are
currently done and one of those problems
is we have all this messy software that
doesn't really work and why do we have
that well people make stuff and they
don't work that hard on it and then they
give it out
and then they let for people
who are using it to run into problems
and then report the problems and like
well
meanwhile you have all these people
experiencing a lot of problems or
slowness or unreliability right and if
you
if your piece of software is very
successful add up all the time that
those people spent experiencing those
problems
it's quite large right even if imagine
only a hundred people used your thing
and you cost them each an hour that's a
hundred hours right that's three and a
half weeks or no two and a half weeks of
full-time work so if you could have
fixed this problem
in let's say it would have taken you two
very hard days of work to fix this
problem that cost these people an hour
um
the the net benefit to everybody is
still a couple weeks right
now
100 users is a very
uh unsuccessful piece of software
actually right okay once you get to the
tens of thousands or millions
these factors are just insane how big
they are right and so what i'm trying to
do is
not create pollution of that kind
right i'm trying to not have negative
externalities so
we're starting with a small group we're
refining the language we're making it
better and we're slowly growing the
number of people right now there's about
100 people
and
i do want to start looking at widening
that soon
in some way that lets people
opt in
but i don't exactly you know we haven't
totally figured it out yet
michael baz paulov says thoughts on
supergiant's success with haiti's early
access model do you think this model
will be more prevalent in the industry
seems like it minimizes risk and
provides valuable feedback in early
stages but doesn't hurt the artistic
vision
i mean i think it's great that their
game was so successful
i don't care that much about business
models
in the sense that if i spend most of my
time like spending a lot of time
thinking about business models is what
most game companies do
and if i want to be different from that
i probably shouldn't do that right um
also my idea of
an artistic process is probably very
different from theirs and
i just don't really do feedback that
much honestly like i use feedback as
um
as a reality check right so like we
might go play test a game somewhere and
we see does the game work
does
does it
like if there are things that we thought
were going to be good did people
get it
get some kind of reasonable response
from them you know but what we don't do
is what play testing typically is which
is
have people answer some questions about
what they like the most and put more of
that in and
what didn't they like and then change
those things or cut them out i mean even
if a lot of people don't like something
in one of my games if it's the right
thing for that game it's in the game you
know it's a very different thing so
um but that's just a different way of
development than what supergiant does um
that's fine that's why you want
a lot of different developers in the
world is because they can do different
things different ways and there's
variety so
early access also i think it's better
for some kinds of games than others
right a game with a lot of replayability
like something like hades early access
makes sense because when you play the
better version later you're like oh cool
right i'm playing the better if you do a
puzzle a single player puzzle game like
the last couple that we've done
if you play the bad version initially
you can't replay it later because you
know how everything goes
so
you just played the bad version right
and then so you're giving your most
enthusiastic people
the bad version of the game and it's
just not good for that kind of a thing
if i think how does the side question
just for me how does play testing work
do you get your family and friends to do
it
is there a company that play tests and
you just put your game there how is it
that people don't break the ndas
because ndas are broken all the time but
oh yeah i rarely hear but i'm i don't
follow game rumors but i rarely hear
about what's happening grand theft auto
6 for example or some other major
relationships how does that work we
don't play tests that much like way less
than most development studios we will
play test
this next game probably more than
previous games but that's because it's
so big and like we just need to do that
to detect problems
the way that we have play tested in the
past was sort of in the beginning you
just have a small number of people that
you know
like friends who are maybe other game
developers or something play it just
because
you just want to see
how it works just just in the beginning
right it's not refined it doesn't have
all the polish like it probably doesn't
even have good art visual art for most
of it so
you don't even expect
like even if your design is correct and
all that and even if the parameters are
all tuned you wouldn't expect the same
final response that you would get from
the finished game because it doesn't
look good it doesn't feel good and all
these things right so you're looking for
a different thing early on
um
later
it's more about testing the final thing
to make sure if it's polished and
make sure weird things don't happen when
people go into some corner that you
never
walked into that way and whatever now
for that kind of thing there are also
like
qa right quality assurance houses which
is kind of like play testing
but
it's different like play testing is like
hey you play it kind of the way a player
would qa is like
it's their job to just try and break the
game all day for weeks or months right
and that's a very useful service but
it's
it's very different from like play
testing but we do engage that in some
way on every game as well
ivan wants to know these are the last
three questions ivan wants to know if
political questions are allowed what are
his thoughts on the state of free speech
in the world now thanks
i'm trying to get away from political
questions there are definitely political
issues that could rile me up um
and i do think
i will say very briefly that i do think
uh
the loss of free speech is kind of a
mistake right but i'm also finding that
in the days that we are living in right
now um having political opinions is very
easy
everybody has one
being loud about them now is very easy
now that we have all this social media
so like i'm not sure that i'm adding
very much
um
by having opinions i will say there is
some value to being
a little a contrarian haven like if you
believe something that's different than
the what's being broadcast from
mainstream news media or something then
you can serve as a little pocket of like
hey there's at least some people who
don't believe this and
you know maybe people can feel less
crazy if they're hanging out but the
thing is that
again like the political rhetoric
is almost completely disingenuous
because people will pretend that they're
standing by big principles when they say
all these things but then they're not
really right they just want whatever the
ends are that
you know and
and so arguing
about principles almost is beside the
point right because most people are
faking right like free speech was made
to be this big principle in the 60s and
70s even in the 80s right
when i was growing up
um
but like
for some reason now all the people in
some particular political area that used
to be very in favor of
free speech is now very anti-free speech
when a lot of the other underlying
values supposedly didn't change and it's
like oh wait that was never really a
principle
that was just a thing that was being
said well for some people it was a
principle okay but for other people it
was just a thing that was being said
an appeal to principles in order to
try to achieve some ends that they
desired right and so
i think that's the majority of what's
going on
i don't
want to participate in that i think
there's just
more important things to think about on
the other hand if we destroy our entire
society through fighting over these
things then
maybe that's bad too right um one thing
that i've definitely learned from
some
spiritually uh
helpful people
is that
you do give energy to something in ways
that you don't intend and i don't mean
energy in a woo new wave thing i just
mean
like look if you if you disagree with
someone about something right
if you argue with them about it first of
all
they're going to argue back and solidify
their stance right so you're actually
whereas they might have just said no big
deal and and changed their mind two
weeks later so you're you're causing the
thing that you don't want to cause right
but secondly
you are becoming the thing that you
thought was not good by engaging in
these arguments
and so forth um
and spending time and energy on those
that are better served
in other directions whatever you think
those directions should be
now i will say i have spent occasional
times now and again arguing with people
on social media about these things
mostly before it became apparent how
widespread some of these beliefs were
going to be and how i wouldn't make a
difference by
saying anything about them right
like if you think ideas are still in
play
then there are reasons to try and
convince people right but if something
is just a wave that's gonna just
annihilate everything then it's like
well
maybe i should just save my energy and
and use it over here instead of over
there um
but also you know
like
there
see that's a confusing thing is there's
always utility to all these things so
like arguing with somebody about
something
um
seems useless but then
maybe someday you it's actually
important that you have these
argumentative skills or have thought
about these things because maybe
maybe you end up in an argument
where somebody's going to make a
decision based on something and that
decision matters in some way against
again we're on the human level and not
like the spiritual level here um
you know maybe that matters
in some human level way
if you didn't think about those things
or you didn't practice arguing with
somebody about them you're kind of not
prepared it's like not
training to fight or something like if
you if you're supposed to protect your
wife and kid
in a rough neighborhood that you live in
right
um if you never learned a fight and then
the day comes that you have to
maybe you were derelict in your duty a
little bit
um
that said though
it's not like people need excuses to
argue with each other right like our
egos want to argue with each other all
the time
so
one has to be very careful
coming up with excuses why that's okay
right
when you were talking about the problems
with our culture you also mentioned
stagnation and around since 1970 or so
um or mid-1970s peter thiel and eric
weinstein have thoughts on that i'm
curious if you've seen their thoughts or
heard their thoughts yeah i've seen a
bunch that both of those guys have said
i have a relatively contrarian view here
in that i agree with peter thiel but
about the general state of things but i
also think
that he's a little too charitable
because what he says is that the domain
of software is
most of the
advancement in recent decades
i actually don't think that's true i
think software stopped advancing around
1990 for the most part we've had small
things that happened but
um i think
this is an area where people are pretty
um
confused about if they don't
think about it all the time because they
look and they say what do you mean
there's all these web companies there's
all these websites they're ipo'ing
there's like billions of dollars and all
that but what's really happening there
is technologies that we figured out in
prior decades like integrated circuits
that go very fast made by companies like
intel amd whatever you know various chip
fabs and all this stuff
combined with like networking and
communications hardware and the material
science that went into that
have made this scenario where you can
have software
that a lot of people use and that's
network connected in a very easy way
right that's actually what created all
of this the actual software in most
cases is pretty dumb and pretty bad and
doesn't really have
new ideas because it doesn't have to
because
you know if you want to make a website
that makes a bunch of money it's not
like you have to have some new
technical software idea to make that
work you just need to make the website
and we've actually known the technology
that you need to work make the website
we've known since like 1965
none of that stuff is new um well let's
if we're talking about networking
specifically let's say 1975 to like give
it more time to percolate but like by
1975 you basically had everything that
you need to build a modern website it's
just we've made it a lot more
complicated than it needs to be and so
people think
people think that things are more rocket
sciencey than they actually are
and so
um when peters thiel says like one of
his big
catch phrases i don't want to you know
that's a little bit of a denigrating way
to say it but like he says you know
we've had very little progress in the
world of atoms and mostly in the world
of bits i don't think we've had very
much progress in the world of bits what
we've had is the use of the world of
bits to generate a lot of economic
windfall which is legitimate right
because we're replacing all sorts of
things that used to have large costs due
to requiring physical manufacturing and
all this stuff right and so
those costs go away so i think it makes
sense that companies make money by
replacing that
but that's not
technological advancement
at all it's just figuring out how to
apply computers to
food delivery or whatever right
so
the other way that i say this is uh
like like everybody in silicon valley
says they work in tech right like oh i
work in tech um i don't think almost any
of these companies are tech companies so
for example uh
if you meet a truck driver and he's
driving at just a regular truck not even
a tesla electric truck or anything a
regular old diesel truck and he's
driving
across the interstate from you know
texas to california to deliver a bunch
of goods does he work in tech
and the answer is probably not
right
um but a truck actually
was amazing technology at some time that
was completely new and even a modern
truck is an iterated refined much better
truck than what we originally knew how
to make so he is driving this amazing
technological artifact right but like we
don't say he works in tech he works in
the application of a particular piece of
technology to
transport and that's not to say anything
you know negative about truck drivers
like those dudes if they all quit right
now we would be in a lot of trouble like
we should have a great deal of respect
for what they do
um
but like there's this pretend that goes
on that what's happening at all these
web companies is fundamentally different
from that but it's not
there it's basically driving trucks
uh from the database to the web client
right
um but they make it a lot harder than it
has to be so it seems like it's more
than that
last question man sure rari vk says if
it's not oh
i think there was a question about the
work process but i don't have the person
like is it scrum is it like lean startup
where you do mvp feedback iterate like
is there a title for what you use as
your work process with your team
um
you know here's the thing
we're not necessary we don't necessarily
have the optimal work process and that's
by design
because at what i was really worried
about working on the witness especially
because that's when the team started
becoming big
i was worried about killing the art
by making it too much of a business or
making it too much of a
of a process right
um that
outputs a product
um like sometimes you need time to
figure things out like how to make them
the best version that they could be
so there were many times on the witness
where it was like you know i don't think
people are doing that much work right
now
because i'm not
guiding them to the right
things that need to be done but i don't
know right now
so i need the time just to take the
break right
now that's bad as the team gets bigger
and bigger and it's more expensive
right
and i think we do some of that still
today but
um
less
but also
you know our model is very loose we have
occasional meetings once in a while
we're working still remotely because of
covid um
and but even before that we had some
remote people
we
have occasional meetings
um but then but not a lot
you know
and um
for the most part we trust
people we hire to be able to execute
some idea all the way down to the end
with only
maybe feedback from a couple teammates
or something about how it's going not
not for me or the whole company
we don't do like
any of these programming methodologies
like agile or scrum or i think those are
all
um
okay those fall into a certain category
of thing right traps
not exactly traps because they're useful
in a certain way there's this broad
category of process um
that is helpful
to people who would otherwise be totally
unproductive whether they're new to
programming or
just find it very hard to focus or
whatever right you put in this certain
level of regularity and discipline and
expected results and all that
and
uh
you improve results for that those
people right
and and also maybe people i think who
this is just a job for them like they're
working on it to make money and to feed
their family or whatever nothing wrong
with that but they're not like
in it right
um
okay
however that acts for people who know
some math it acts kind of like a
bandpass filter where you filter out the
poor results but you also filter out the
amazing outlier results because like
sometimes you just need
a dude who's bad at certain things
to be on the team because he's good at
certain other he's amazing at certain
other things right
or
sometimes you need you know
people who
don't really show results on something
for a long time because they're
ruminating on it
and then eventually something good comes
out right and so
um if you forbid all those things from
happening
then
that's bad right because you're you're
selecting away those results so that's
why we don't do those
final question rory vk says if it's not
too late she submitted this last name
why is it called the witness
i i can't tell you that
sorry
um
you know
it was the name that was
it was the name that was most right for
the game
that i was able to come up with um
and the reasons for that are many and
they're intertwined and
they're things that i don't really
because like i said i don't want to be
in the business of saying what games are
about
they're
things like that and so
um
i think that's
all i can say on that
jonathan it's i'm
i'm
i'm honored to have spoken with you yeah
it was a good time i mean we went almost
five hours we started late or no we
didn't we didn't four three and a half
four yeah yeah that's that's plenty long
you know
thank you so much yeah thanks for
talking to me and i um
you know
have have a good time continuing to do
your
your interview series and i hope it
continues to go well
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l
that is kurt jaimungle it's support from
the patrons and from the sponsors that
allow me to do this full time every
dollar helps tremendously thank you